Hello, everybody!
I am... I am a mess right now.
But when am I not a mess?
That's a good question.
I literally just installed Fortnite, like, my installation of Fortnite just stopped, like, finished, like, ten minutes ago.
Because I forgot I didn't install Fortnite on this PC.
Anyway, um, we have our Fortnite bodyguard, Doryu.
Um, he plays Fortnite a lot.
By the way, I need you guys to know, um, I had, I had, like, three other Fortnite pros that were supposed to play with me, but then they, like, I don't know, I think they found out I wasn't a Fortnite player and they dropped out.
So I'm glad, Doryu, you didn't drop out.
I didn't drop out.
Let me tell you a story.
So they asked me, the staff, Twitch staff asked me, um, asked me if, like, if I was willing to join the Fortnite Twitch Rivals.
And I was like, how sweaty is it?
And then they were like, oh, it's pretty sweaty.
And I was like, oh.
And I was like, uh, um, can you give me a Fortnite pro?
I can, I can do it, but, like, I think I need a Fortnite pro.
And they're like, don't worry, we got you.
Um, so then, so then three, I, we had three different people that we asked and, like, yeah.
Cause I was like, hey, um, I don't know about this.
Seems like this, I thought, you know, there'd be, like, people like me, you know, I thought there'd be, like, people like me.
And then I looked at the roster and then, cause, like, some, one of them suggested, the staff suggested me to recruit this player.
And I looked up this person's Twitter and they were, like, a fucking Fortnite professional.
And then they're, and they're recruiting for their Fortnite Twitch rivals.
They were, like, looking for a pro Fortnite pro player for Twitch rivals.
And I'm like, but he's already pro.
What, what do you mean?
Why is he looking for a Fortnite pro if he's already pro?
What do you mean?
I thought it'd be, like, you know, not pro with pro.
And this is what I would say.
I was like, hey, are there any other teams, like, like me?
And they're like, no, don't worry.
There's an Overwatch team as well.
There's, like, two Overwatch players together, um, in a team together.
Um, so they're just like you.
I'm like, okay.
But I looked at it and it's J3 and Apply.
Apply is in, you know, has been in Overwatch Cup.
J3 has been top 500 for, like, since Overwatch began.
So I was just like, oh.
I was just like, oh.
And then we, and then finally we got it.
We got an Overwatch pro.
Not Overwatch pro.
We got Fortnite.
We got, we got a Fortnite pro.
We got a Fortnite pro.
And literally, we met up.
We were like, hey, I'm not, I'm not a Fortnite player.
Is that okay?
And then the guy was like, oh, don't worry.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
We got this.
I was like, oh, thank God.
Okay.
Um, and then, like, literally, like, 15 minutes later, I got a message from the staff.
It was like, we need to find a new player.
And I was like, what happened?
And then the guy that was supposed to be my duo messaged me and was like, sorry, we had a family emergency.
I have to drop out.
I was like, we met for 15 minutes.
I was like, what?
We met for 15 minutes and then you got a family emergency?
What is my luck?
And that was like an hour before, an hour before Twitch rivals, um, an hour before Twitch rivals start.
So luckily we managed to get, we managed to get Doryu, who plays a lot of Fortnite.
Um, and I was like, that's my new bodyguard.
I have a new bodyguard.
I finally have, I have another.
It took us a while, but we got another Fortnite bodyguard.
Um, so I hope I'll live long enough in this tournament.
I can't believe I, the 15 minute part was the most absurd.
Literally we were in a group chat with me and the Twitch staff and the other pro.
I was like, hey, I don't play Fortnite.
And then we were discussing drops too.
They're like, oh yeah, what kind of, what place do you want to land?
And I was like, oh, I don't know.
You can pick it.
You pretend, I know like I'm captain by name, but like you can, you can decide everything.
And then 15 minutes later, family emergency.
So my, my Fortnite bodyguard is an actual wolf.
Um, we can't lose this.
We literally have an actual werewolf.
So like, we can't lose this.
It's like that ZZZ game, right?
Where people were thirsting over that wolf boy.
Like, like I have a wolf boy too.
So like, we'll be fine.
It's just like that wolf boy.
I have zero context of like what, what that guy is, but like, but like if that, if ZZZ can survive a wolf boy, maybe I can survive with also a wolf boy.
All right.
Okay.
I don't know where we're starting.
I'm going to unmute.
Hey, who are you?
Are we supposed to, do we have the code for the game yet?
Or like, no, not yet.
I'm like watching it right now.
Everyone is, I think still like getting situated.
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm watching the general chat right now.
Okay.
That's good.
Anyway, did you read the rules?
Cause there's a lot of rules.
And I, I read one paragraph and I was like, I, I already tuned it out.
So I assume your brain was just like naughty?
No, it's so long.
Like why is the rules so long?
I don't know.
Let me be your guide wolf and I will, I will be the slightly lesser smooth brain.
Cause I'm very smooth.
Yeah.
Like it's so long.
Okay.
That's for day two.
Oh, nevermind.
Day two is crazy, but day one is going to be bad.
We're not going to make it.
I was like, you have great confidence.
I'm like, no.
Okay.
You don't understand.
Like I did.
I told them the story of like how we ended up getting you, but basically I had three different Fortnite pros that dropped out.
Are you serious?
No fucking way.
And then the last Fortnite pro, the last four, like they were all Twitch aside too.
They were trying to like assign me a pro player.
Cause I was like, please, I need a Fortnite pro.
Like if you want me in this tournament, I'm not going to survive.
I feel your pain.
And then, um, and then like, and then so like, like Todd told them like the last Fortnite pro we like, I literally, we got in a group chat.
It was like an hour before the tournament before Twitch rivals.
And then we were like in a group chat, like we got them at like, um, 12 or something, 12 PM.
And then, and then like, and then we were like talking, I was like, Hey, I don't play Fortnite.
Is that okay?
And then he was like, yeah, that's fine.
It's cool.
And then, and then we're like, yeah, where do you want to travel?
It's like, I don't care.
I don't, I don't know what I'm doing.
Like, this is all on you, man.
And then 15 minutes later, he messaged me.
It's like, sorry, family emergency.
I can't do it.
Did their family emergency not be a family emergency?
Like literally right before the Like, wait, no, she's bad, bad.
Alright, got a phone in a family emergency.
Okay, do they even know that you used to play Apex?
Like, yeah, I said, I was like, Oh, I'm an Apex Overwatch player.
And then, but I honestly think it was, it could be, it could be a family emergency.
But like the timing, that was fucking crazy.
15 minutes after, like, I don't know, like realization struck for him.
And he's like, wait a minute.
I was fucking brushing my teeth, checking my phone.
I need somebody that knows how to play Fortnite.
You give me too much credit.
I know how to die very fast.
There's clips of you.
No, you're supposed to be my bodyguard.
You were like the last hope.
I don't remember this episode of Fortnite.
I, what is it called?
Like, is it literally like Dory, the last protector?
In reality, he's actually a big inting.
I'll eat the bullets.
No, you're not supposed to eat the bullets.
You're supposed to kill them.
Jogi, we're doomed.
We're doomed.
Oh, no, it's okay.
We're not going to make it to day two.
What if we make it to day two?
What if we're literally off on the board?
Then God actually hates us.
And God said, let there be VTubers and furry VTubers.
Oh my God.
You have sinned.
I fucking, we're fucked.
Okay.
Jogi, we ready.
We fucking ready.
Oh my God.
Okay, they have the code.
We're supposed to be in a party together.
Yeah, here, let me invite you.
Let me invite you.
Also, are you Peter Griffin?
No, I'm John Cena now, so they can't see me.
I do have Peter Griffin, though.
Should I be Peter?
Wait, I could be Peter.
I could be whatever chat wants me to be.
Wait, what is chat going to make you?
Because then I can be something to match you.
Well, I have Meeseeks too.
Yeah, I have Meeseeks.
We could be Rick and Meeseeks.
Do you have Rick?
Uh, I don't have... Yeah, I have Rick.
Wait, you have Rick?
Oh my God!
Yeah, I'm being Rick.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's great.
Okay, wait.
How do I...
How do I go back to... Wait, am I not?
Oh, wait.
Am I not?
Join party.
Okay.
Oh my God.
You have Morty!
I have Morty!
Same character.
Okay, okay.
Morty and Meeseeks.
Okay, they'll know who to kill first.
That's great.
They'll know who to get for easy points.
That's how we're going to send the message.
Um, I think I need to... Okay, let me enter the code real quick.
Yeah, yeah.
You do the code entering.
Ready.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I got it.
So, guys, how's Doryu?
Is Doryu's volume okay?
Yeah, same for you guys, chat.
Can you guys hear Doki fine?
Yeah, yeah.
Can you hear Doryu okay?
And can you hear me okay?
As long as I'm loud in Doryu, that's all that matters.
But also, you can't be like... You can't hear him.
My brain is still burning up.
I literally, like, got home, like, 30 minutes ago to install Fortnite.
Deadass.
Oh my God.
Doryu, we're so ready.
We are so fucking ready.
We're so ready.
Okay, hit ready on that.
Okay, let me... I'm going to boost you up a little bit.
And then... Alright.
Okay, I boosted you up.
Chat, I got Morty on his back.
Or I got Rick on his back, okay?
Where's Rick?
Oh, you got Pickle Rick?
Wait, I think I have Pickle Rick, too.
Wait, actually, I don't know.
I buy a lot of stuff.
I have the snake... the pickaxe for the snake.
Oh, you got the snake pickaxe, too?
Yo, I'm going to hook that.
Yo, I'm fucking doing it.
I'm doing it.
Guys, you have to be, like, at a certain IQ to understand this.
Uh, let's see.
Wait, wait, wait.
Uh, what's it called?
It's called the snake?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Alright, we're so fucking back.
Funniest shit ever, guys.
Oh, you're fucking endless.
They ain't even ready.
Yeah, yeah.
They know we're a great team.
We're, like, matching.
We got the drip.
Exactly.
Am I supposed to radio up?
Oops.
Yeah, yeah, go ahead and radio.
Alright, we're fine.
By the way, I was watching.
I was checking your stream out.
Because we went live earlier.
And you were doing game training.
I just want you to know, I was definitely not doing any of that.
Yo, but were you doing food training?
Because I'm...
Yeah, I was definitely not warming up.
The last time I shot the pew pew was at four in the morning two days ago.
Because I was ringing for an Apex scrim.
Yo, wait, you were doing Apex scrims?
No, it was for, like, somebody's... it was for a Japanese tournament.
So, like, I was ringing for somebody.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, who are you going to be playing?
Man, can you believe we haven't played Apex since, like, three years ago?
Yeah, I think that's like three or four years ago.
Three or four years ago when we did that Apex rank grind.
Yeah, we ancient.
Yeah, we're fucking old.
Yeah, you used to still be... you weren't a werewolf yet.
You used to be full fleshy.
I used to be a gross human flesh tuber.
Yeah, and then you got bit by a wolf.
Yeah, you guys don't get bit by a wolf.
And then you got that dog in you.
You was that 00... that ZZZ wolf before ZZZ came out.
Oh, husbando.
Oh, God.
Wait, you're like 30-something, right?
Yeah, I'm like... I'm ancient AFM.
Oh my God, you're old old.
Yeah, I'm like literally old old.
Oh my God.
I'm like Krusty Krusty.
I invented the Krusty Krab.
That's all about it.
Holy shit.
Oh my God.
Yo, how did you befriend a Krusty-ass Krusty Krab like me?
Apex?
I don't remember.
I think it was like a friend of a friend in Apex.
And then we just like played in rank.
Oh, I think it was like a rank.
Yeah, it was rank, yeah.
Yeah, we needed a plus one.
I don't know if it was you who needed a plus one or I needed a plus one.
But we were granting rank or something for Apex.
Wait, was that like LFG back then?
Was it LFG?
In Apex Discord?
I don't remember.
I feel like it might have been.
I feel like it might... Yeah, because like...
Otherwise, it would have been through... No, it had to be through a friend.
I think it was through a friend.
Because I remember one of us needed like a plus one for rank.
And then we were trying to get Pred or something.
And we were just LFG-ed.
We just like...
We were like, oh, I know some...
Like a mutual friend was like, we know somebody.
And it was like you or me.
God, like...
Wait, was it you that tweeted that clip from Apex days?
Yeah, yeah.
When we were like WKing?
When we was like me, you, and Sang.
And we like fucking killed like some fucking pro Pred team.
And they were like, what?
Because I didn't...
I stopped grinding rank at that time.
So I was Plat.
And then he was like, who the fuck is this Plat player?
DokiBread.
Who the fuck is she?
Or they don't even say, is he?
Who the fuck is he?
We were being so gremlin.
Yeah, because they were like, he's Plat.
What the fuck?
Yeah, look at this Plat Doki.
DokiBread looking ass.
Yeah, yeah, because we shit on them.
They were literally like top ten Pred or whatever.
Damn.
Oh my god.
I've not been playing Apex at all.
I'm still watching that game now.
Oh, it's alright.
Same here.
Doki, we in this.
We in this.
Wait, where are you?
I don't know.
I'm still connecting.
Oh my god, it's us.
Look, it's us.
We had a pick a rank fight.
Wait, what emotes you got?
What emotes you got?
Wait, I don't remember.
What button is it?
I think I have B on mine.
Oh shit, we're like going...
Where's your drop spot?
We're going here.
So land on the blue mark.
Land on the blue mark.
That's yours.
Let me know when to drop.
That's all yours.
Do I drop?
Uh, drop...
Now.
Drop now.
Okay.
I'm gonna go here.
And I'm gonna get all the loot from that and I'll run over here.
Oh, so I land on the red, right?
Yeah, you land on the red.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Guys, is Dory's volume better now or does he need to be lifted up more?
Yay!
Let's go!
I have no idea what the equipments are, so...
Oh, there's the plunger gun.
Literally run everything and anything you want to run.
Okay, cool.
And I will try to like...
And then you do everything else.
Basically, basically.
I'll just exist.
Yeah, yeah, I'll exist.
Yeah, yeah.
As long as I'm alive, then we've already accomplished a lot.
You have, um...
You know about shields and stuff, though, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, cool.
Yeah, I know.
I know about shields.
I have cosmetics, so at least I know that.
You know that cosmetics?
Whoa!
What did I do?
Oh, there's a little trampoline.
Alright, I got all my loot over here, so I'm gonna run with you.
Wait, I got a fucking trampoline thing.
Oh, those are really, really good.
I think I actually already used it.
The thing...
Oh, yeah, if you double jump, it like auto-deploys it, which is really annoying.
Yeah, because I was like, what the fuck?
How did that happen?
Wait, how do I...
Just watch in the house.
I'm gonna try to find us like...
So you know how in build mode, everyone turns into like a freaking tower or whatever?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
By the way, I have...
I dropped a grappler if we want it.
Oh, you don't want that?
I don't think I can use it.
I don't think it's smart for me to use it.
Do you want to use shockwaves?
Do you know how to use shockwaves?
What's shockwaves?
It's the purple thing that basically like launches you into the air.
Oh, yeah, no.
Any movement stuff, do not rely on me for this game.
Look, my job is to exist.
What do I drop?
What do I drop, though?
Oh, wait, what guns are you using?
I have...
Okay, I'll drop... I have one gun.
Do you want a shotgun?
No, I'll take this gun.
This gun is tracking.
I can track.
Yo, okay, okay, okay.
So if you're gonna take tracking, I'm trying to think of what the other good weapons are.
Because the bloom is fucking booty in this game.
It's so annoying.
Oh, I don't know what any of those words are.
The RNG in the bullets is very, very bad.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, bloom, bloom, as in FPS.
Okay, I thought it was like a Fortnite word.
I thought you were using a Fortnite word on me.
No, Orlando Bloom is atrocious because he's gonna be in the co-op very soon.
Okay.
So zone is closing and... wait, what the hell?
We're right next to it.
We're next to the zone.
Oh, hey, there it is.
Oh, there's a chest there.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
So you see these little bunkers right here on the ground?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, I know the portal bunkers.
Grab those.
It's okay.
We're right next to the zone.
I'm gonna slash this guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
All right, let's go to the right?
All right, sure.
Let's go through here.
Come here, Meeseeks.
Oh, my God.
Wait, somebody's dead.
We're not last.
No, we're not last.
We're vibing.
We're fucking vibing right now.
Oh, we're not last.
Let's go.
We're actually vibing.
Let's fucking go.
We're doing so much already.
Yo, all we gotta do is exist, okay?
That's all we have to do.
We already got points for not being last.
Let's go.
Yeah, we're fucking chilling right now.
We should, like, change our skins every game just so they don't farm us.
I'm down.
Oh, there's a team here.
I'm gonna go back real quick.
Let's go around.
Let's try to be evasive.
Okay.
Let's go, like, over here.
Yeah.
It was a condom skin.
You know the gray superhero ones?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold on.
They're gonna be to the right.
Oh, yeah, they see us.
Oh, they do.
They do.
Oh, they're jumping up.
Let's go over here.
Yeah, no, I feel like they have matching skins, too.
So, they could be really, really good matching skins or really, really bad matching skins like us.
They might be just as scared as us.
That's true.
Oh, my God.
I keep watching back.
They're gonna be probably mirroring us over here.
Oh, there's a team over here.
All right.
Let's go under the bridge.
Okay.
Let's go here.
All right.
I'm heading down with you.
I'm looking for you.
Oh, we're chilling here.
We're chilling.
All right.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna just kind of crouch here.
We can just, we can vibrate here.
Oh, I hear them shooting.
They're shooting already.
Not last.
Yeah, we're chilling.
Look at me, number one.
Level 146.
You said you didn't play.
I don't play this game.
What do you mean?
Level 146.
I'm literally level one.
Yeah, that's scrub levels, right?
That's scrub.
What am I?
You're Mr. Meeseeks.
You got a little...
I'm level one.
What am I, then?
You're...
I don't know.
You're level...
Can they hear that?
They definitely can't hear me.
What the fuck?
Now they know we're down here.
No, we're chilling.
I think I'd be super close to it, so know that we're here.
They apparently said I don't have the visual feedback.
Oh, you don't?
Okay, hold on.
I got an idea.
Hit escape.
Oh, no, actually, don't do it.
There's people above us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say.
I didn't...
I don't know.
You're gonna be right here?
I didn't turn that off.
Okay, I'll watch for us.
I'm watching for us.
Okay.
Oh, this thing got cracked above us?
We might be able to get them if they, like...
Dropped out?
Yep, 38.
Wait, what?
They are right above us.
We're gonna put pressure on them if they try to, like...
Don't look down.
We're gonna have to move, so...
Oh, fuck, I have a crown!
I'm so dumb.
Wait, you have a crown?
What's that?
Yeah, I did not want this crown.
Oh, it means I won the last game.
Oh, we didn't turn that off!
That's so unfair!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Doki, Doki, come here.
Come, come, come, come.
Look at this, look at this, look at this.
We can choose guys in the back.
3, 2, 1.
The one on the left.
Oh, no, never mind.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, well, we're gonna go to the left then.
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, yep, I'm gonna do this.
Okay.
I'm gonna do this again.
And I'm gonna splash us.
Nice.
Oh my god, that was a quick reaction.
You want my portal bunker?
Uh, carry.
You sure you don't want to carry it?
No, I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Okay, so follow me here.
Follow me, follow me.
We're gonna crouch.
We're gonna go to the side.
Am I crouching?
No.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There you go, there you go.
Okay, get ready.
And we're gonna run in 3, 2, 1.
Let's start going.
Okay.
We're gonna see this team in a sec.
Oh, they're right in front.
I'm gonna get on here.
We're gonna show on the left.
Uh, okay.
Doki, we're gonna have to go over here.
So, stand right on me.
Stand right on me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, we're gonna show on the back.
What the fuck?
What are they doing here?
I got us, I got us, I got us.
Okay.
Uh, okay.
So, do you know how to shockwave yourself?
We'll find out.
Take that thing and use it like a pathfinder.
Okay.
Alright.
Like this?
Oh, shit!
Oh, did I knock you?
No!
Hey, we got 16!
I think you shocked me into the other team.
No, it doesn't look kind of good.
Oh, fuck.
Do you think you shocked me?
No, no, no, that was all part of the plan.
It was gonna be an evasive shockwave and then we're gonna go...
That was part of the plan.
What was the plan?
Oh, they have the apex thing now.
They have that thing.
Wait, you had the grapple.
Oh, I had the plunger grapple.
I could have used that.
They're using my...
Yeah, plunge.
They're using my plunge.
Oh, that's where you died.
Yeah, that's where I died at.
Yeah.
See these skins?
These are what we call the condom skins.
Oh, wait.
So, you do play Fortnite.
You know all the lingo.
You know the lingo.
Yeah, Chad.
Do you guys know about the condom skins?
Wait, okay.
So, how do I turn on the audio feedback?
So, under settings, go to...
Oh, is it the very last one?
Oh, no, no.
I think it's under...
Oh, where is it?
I gotta find it again.
Is it visual sound effects?
Yeah, yeah.
It's that one.
Just turn that on.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, all right.
We're good.
We're good to go.
Guys.
Yo, we weren't dead last.
We were not dead last.
Yeah, we're not last.
How many teams are in it?
Per game?
I think it's 40 teams.
I think.
What?
We did it all the way?
20 teams.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should have lied and said 40, so I felt happier.
I think if I remember right now...
Let me look at the team numbers.
Yeah, out of 20 teams, we were...
I think...
Twelve?
No, we were 16.
We played 16.
We were 16?
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, we were 16.
I'm like, there's numbers at the top.
There's literally a number right there at the top.
There's literally a number at the top.
I was like, where did you get the 12 from?
I'm like over here looking at Discord.
Like, hold on.
Let me put on my nerd glasses real quick.
Yeah, yeah.
I got them.
All right.
Let me...
Okay.
My audio guy said, turn you down just a little bit.
And then boost up the audio.
So give me a sec.
I'm going to turn you down just a little bit.
And then...
All right, guys.
Does the game sound a lot better, chat?
Does the game sound a lot better?
Yeah, how does Doki sound to you guys?
Is Doki pretty okay?
Thank you, Sombob.
Thank you.
All right.
I just got to make sure.
All right, guys.
That was our warm-up game.
Yeah, that was a warm-up.
That was literally the warm-up game.
That was a warm-up, chat.
I had literally no idea what I'm doing.
I still don't, but like now...
At least, like, I know a little bit more.
That's all that matters.
What the fuck?
They said no build.
Put all these port-a-bunkers.
Yo, fucking...
This is what I tell chat all the time.
I'm like, yo, I love Zero Hell.
How is it no build if there's bunkers?
Thank you.
That's counterintuitive to no building.
Because we're still building our bunker.
I literally complain about this all the time.
I'm like, I love Zero Hell.
Zero build, wait.
I love...
Oh my god, that's how you do...
Oh my god, that's how you do the jump.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
She's still dead.
Yeah, you like...
You throw...
You basically throw...
It's like a grenade.
You like throw it at your feet.
And then it'll launch you wherever direction that your character is standing on.
Oh.
I see.
But the nice thing about this mode is that it responds...
Did you ever play Three Strikes?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like Three Strikes.
It's like Three Strikes in Fortnite.
Yeah.
So, as long as one person's still alive, we're chilling.
These guys are such nerds.
They're doing, like, same skin.
They're not...
I know, right?
You could do, like, matching themed skin.
That's like...
You know how, like, um...
Like...
Beta...
Betas use same skin.
Alpha and Sigma males use matching themed.
Yeah, I don't see any, like...
There is no chat right now.
Everyone's using a condom.
Same skin is boring.
It's all about the theme.
It's the theming of the skin.
Wait, do you have Dragon Ball skins?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have all the good ones.
Which one do you want?
Do you have all of them as well?
I think I do, yeah.
I'm pretty sure I have all the...
Well, all the first wave.
Because I think they did a second wave of, like, Dragon Ball skins.
I have, like...
I have Frieza and Cell and Vegeta.
What?
Do you have Frieza and Cell?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have Goku too, I think.
Oh, so jelly.
Okay, I don't have Frieza.
But I do have Goku and, like, Vegeta.
Oh, okay.
Wait, we could do Goku, Vegeta.
I got Team Big Forehead.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Do we want to do the...
Or we do villains.
Do we want to do villain hero or just the heroes?
I'm down.
I'm down for villains.
Villain hero?
Okay.
I can do Frieza and you can be Goku.
All right.
The teamwork of the century.
The collab of the century.
Frieza and Goku working together in Fortnite to beat the Fortnite players.
Kakarot.
I must beat Fortnite players.
I can't believe it.
The team up.
They teamed up together so they can beat Fortnite.
I never foresaw this happening.
If you ever asked me in the past.
I can't believe it.
The ending we all wanted.
The tournament of power loss episode.
Let's go.
I am so happy that out of all the teams that are playing in this tourney, no one is ready for Team Kakarot and Vegeta.
No, we're Frieza.
Frieza, I mean.
Yeah, Frieza.
How could you?
Fake fan.
No.
Not like this.
You're a fake fan.
You try to pretend you're a real fan by using Kakarot, but you're a fake fan.
You mistaken Frieza with Vegeta.
I'm more of a Naruto fan.
I can't believe it.
I have not watched Dragon Ball since, I think, Z?
What was after Z?
They did GT on Cartoon Network.
GT, which is not canon.
Yeah, which is not canon and doesn't exist in Dragon Ball eyes.
I know one person that is sinned by GT being amazing and otherwise everyone has sinned against it.
Wait, you think GT is amazing?
Me?
No, no.
I do not think so.
Okay, okay.
I was going to say, then we know you're an actual fake fan.
I remember when, you know, in Dragon Ball, they Dragon Balled and then they, like, did the Z thing and then they know when Naruto...
What is the Z thing in your world?
Holy shit, this guy's a Fortnite player.
Oh, you want to know what Z means?
You want to know how I got the fucking Z?
Yeah.
It's literally because someone took Doryu on Twitch.
Oh, so then you're like, Doryu Z.
Yeah, so like, everyone who's like, yo, what's the cool lore to your name?
I'm like, I couldn't take my original name.
That's my lore.
Fake Dragon Ball fan over here.
I was like, his name is Naruto, Goku is his dad.
And you know when Bulma, like, did the Bulma thing and then...
Yeah, you know when Bulma and Sakura, like, worked together to rescue Boruto and then after that, that, like, Bleached Man came over and...
Yeah.
I can't believe...
Sasuke Kurosaki, right?
Yeah, yeah.
And then, like, Sasuke came over with Luffy D-something to help him find the One Piece.
That's it, right?
You know, I was hurting my brain by trying to formulate all these thoughts.
But, like, we're hurting our brain collectively as a team right now.
Wait, Bleached Man's name isn't Bleach?
He has an actual name?
Yeah, you know, his name is Man Bleach or John Bleach.
Oh, it's John Bleach Man, right?
John Bleach Man, yeah.
Yeah, when he carries that big-ass gun, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From that one Final Fantasy game.
And he's out there to find the Dragon Balls.
Yeah, and then he throws the Dragon Balls and then he summons Ifrit, right?
Yeah, yeah, and then he summons Vegeta.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that was such a good episode.
That's, like, the big-ass monkey.
Vegeta, the monkey.
Oh, you mean that Tarzan?
Tarzan?
Yeah.
Wait, they made Japanese Tarzan?
You know, they probably did.
There's just a fanfic of, like, anime Tarzan.
And then they saved the world!
I guarantee someone is searching it right now on, like, DeviantArt.
If DeviantArt even still is alive.
So I lost all my fans by butchering five different big fandoms in anime.
Five of the biggest anime fandoms ever.
But we didn't slander Evangelion yet, though.
Evangelion?
Which I literally just watched it for the first time.
Did you realize, like, the company went bankrupt recently?
Wait, what?
Yeah, for, like, money laundering or something.
Are you talking about Studio Trigger or the studio behind it?
The original studio behind it.
They, like, Jesus Christ, what the fuck am I watching?
Why is there a fucking easter egg head?
There's an easter egg head.
That's what it was, Genix.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Genix died years ago, but they officially died recently.
Like, as in, like, I think, like, there was a news article saying they just, like, recently got, like, a sentence or whatever.
What?
Like, the directors for, like, behind, the CEO behind Genix.
Oh my god, the condom man won!
Yo, what?
A condom man?
There's several condom men?
Yo.
There's several condom men.
So fucking sweaty.
I feel like, when the condom skins get put on, you know that, like, clown image of the guy in the mirror?
Yeah.
Like, putting the makeup on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like the condom skins, like, it's time.
Why do you think they're so cool?
Other games don't think you're cool with the condom man skin.
They think you're fucking nerds.
You're basically the bald wraith of Apex.
That's not a compliment.
I have always called him the bald wraith of Apex.
I fucking love you.
Yeah, you can be exact.
It's almost like, you can literally be Goku.
Why would you be a condom?
Exactly!
That's what I'm saying.
How do we back out?
Return to lobby?
Yeah, I think we back out.
Yeah, return to lobby.
Alright, I'm gonna be...
You can literally be...
You can be Eddie!
You can be the fucking people in Lethal Company!
They literally added Lethal Company in Fortnite and you decided to be a condom?
No, I wanna be a condom.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Anyway, I'm gonna be Frieza.
Alright, so I'm being Vegeta, right?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, Goku.
Oh, I'm gonna be Goku, okay.
Alright, I'm gonna see what's in the shop.
What the fuck is this?
The signature style?
Do you see that?
The Mad Mochi outfit?
Oh, is it the big, like, the thing that looks like they're from Super Mario?
What?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, like the build-up.
A tall, like, mochi ball man.
Yeah!
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
You can literally be a Mad Mochi person.
Oh my god, I thought you had the blue...
Guys, by the way, if you wanna support a creator, you can use that Doki Bird right here.
So, um, when you buy stuff...
Yeah, use code Doki Bird.
No, chat, use code Doki.
Yeah, yeah, Doki Bird.
Doki Bird, Doki Bird.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, it's the weekend.
Lady Gaga's in here?
Yeah, they have Lady Gaga, they have Ariana Grande.
Oh my god, I was so behind.
The only thing I remember from it was the Lethal Company men in there.
Doki, the night is young.
We can literally play so many combos.
Oh my god, there's, like, oh, they added more Marvel characters.
Yeah, we could literally be Thanos and, like, Black Widow.
Or we could be...
Oh my god.
I can't believe Pius the Caribbean is in here.
Right?
What the fuck?
They're doing a big update on Friday, where they're gonna add a bunch of, like, Pirates of the Caribbean stuff.
Oh!
And they're adding in this, like, pirate ship movement item, where, like, you basically, like...
What?
Yeah, I think you, like, summon a ghost pirate ship.
You guys summon a ghost pirate ship?
What the fuck?
Yeah, yeah.
Isn't that broken?
Does that seem...
Oh, that's why Fortnite competitive is dead.
Don't say a lot of them in the back.
Now I understand.
How the fuck do you balance a giant pirate ship?
Like, how the fuck?
Okay, I think I got all the right stuff equipped right now.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Let me see what I can equip, too.
I got Frieza.
What are you doing in the back?
For the back?
Oh, for the back?
Yeah, yeah.
I have the oxygen tank.
Oh, you have the oxygen tank?
Okay.
Do you have a crewmate?
Like the little Amogus?
No, I didn't buy it.
Yeah, I think they have that for when they start selling the game on Epic.
No, I don't have it.
I have...
Let's see.
I'll put it on baby bender.
You're going to put baby bender?
Oh, baby bender.
I have that, too.
I'm going to put baby bender.
And then my pickaxe is still going to be...
I'm going to keep my pickaxe the same because I don't think we're going to be using that much often.
Yeah.
Should I put on Yoda?
I can put Yoda on my back.
Oh, is he a baby Yoda?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Baby bender.
It's grown-ass.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Grown-ass Yoda.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait, how do I turn yourself back so I can see it?
Oh, wait.
I can do an emote.
Let me do an emote real quick.
Okay, okay.
I want to see baby Yoda.
Or, like, grown-ass Yoda.
I think he'll jump on the back.
No, okay.
Never mind.
He does not jump on the back.
Wait, what about...
Uh...
This one?
I can barely...
I, like, sort of see it.
I gotta find one where I just turn around.
Where's the turn-around one, Chat?
Oh, wait.
Did we get the next code?
Oh, okay.
We got the next code?
We did.
We got the next code.
Okay.
Uh...
Let me enter the...
We'll never see big, grown-ass Yoda.
Alright, let me...
Okay, I got it.
Okay, go ahead and ready up.
Alright.
What else do I have?
I have...
The Macarena.
What do you have?
Oh, yeah!
Wait, I have that, too!
Let's go!
No, you got a one.
Let's fucking go!
Bring back this era!
Oh, my God!
The moment I saw that in the store, I needed to have it.
Have you actually watched that video again recently?
Yeah.
Did you watch the video where they all got together and recreated?
They got together again?
Yeah, they got together and recreated!
And you can see that it's not the same because they went corporate.
Some of them became businessmen and women.
And you can see that it's not as good as before.
Dang!
Life hit them hard.
Corporate hit them hard.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh, my God.
Wait, okay.
What was it called?
Was it a goth dance?
It's called Infectious.
Oh, it's a cyber goth dance party.
Okay.
Cyber goth.
They just went...
Oh, it's called the video, right?
Cyber goth dance reunion.
And you can tell it's not the same.
My boyfriend and I were talking about it the other day.
And we were like, dang.
You know, everyone used to make fun of them back then.
And then the comment section changed to everyone vibing with them.
Everybody was just like, God, I wish I could feel the joy they felt back then.
Right.
Their soul.
And then the moment they went and became adults, their soul was gone.
Hey, would you type in cyber goth party?
Cyber goth dance.
Cyber goth dance reunion?
I don't know.
I don't remember.
I saw like a video of it, but I don't know.
I don't know where I found it.
What was the cyber goth dance reunion?
I like how there's like a video pops up called goth rave at a funeral.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I found it.
I'm going to link it.
Send it.
I'm going to link it in my chat first.
And then I'll send it over.
All right.
I need to make sure I can send it.
Guys, it's not the same.
You can tell.
One of them is literally wearing a suit.
It's not.
It's not the same.
Why is this like a 10 year reunion?
Oh, my God.
It's like 12 years later.
That's crazy.
This guy, one of them just came back from work and he's like, all right, don't worry.
I'll be here.
There's some very interesting results.
I love seeing all these different things I'm like going through right now.
That was 10 years ago.
12 years ago.
You can see it.
It's not the same.
It was before they got real jobs.
Before they became adults.
I never saw this ending.
That guy in the fishnet shirt, though.
Holy shit.
I'll pull up your stream.
I gotta see it on your side.
No, I'm not even looking at it.
I'm not looking at the stream.
This is on my other tab.
They changed that.
Reality hit them hard.
And they became businessmen.
They had to earn money.
They had to make money.
And pay taxes.
Wait, this is them?
Yeah, that's them.
It's the reunion.
They were sore for days after that.
This is what's going to give us power for the next game.
Exactly, right here.
We're gonna...
We're gonna bring back CyberGoth.
What?
I gotta pause it.
Dang, look at her.
What?
Oh my God.
The main one at the front is the guy who was at the front of the other video.
I think they're all placed in the same spot, right?
Yeah.
What?
That's so crazy.
We're bringing it back.
We gotta sync it up.
A buddy in my chat said they're...
They're basically Fortnite skins.
Wait, we gotta sync the dance.
You guys ready to emote together?
Yo, yo, wait, we sync it?
Yeah, three...
Wait, okay, wait.
Okay.
Let me...
Wait, I have it on.
Okay, three, two, one, go.
I just defeated them!
Okay, we got this, we got this.
Okay, you count down, you count down.
Okay, three, two, one, go.
No, we're so close!
We're so close!
Okay, three, two, one, go.
Yes!
No!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, we look so good!
Wait, mine even synced on my end.
Wait, you synced on my end?
As long as it synced on someone's side, that's all that matters.
It's like, to the frame, it's actually, like, perfect.
We're gonna bring back Cybergod!
Yeah, this is the revival here.
This is the revival.
The revival is coming.
It's happening.
Pretty perfect.
I think it's great that we used Dragon Ball Z skins for Cybergod.
I also just love that you're running like Baby Bender on your back.
You have Adult Yoda and I have Baby Bender.
Wait, what other ones do you have?
Let me see if I have, like...
What's this one?
I wish you had, like, Baby Yoda.
Oh my god, why does he look like that?
Yoda looks so fucking off.
I know, right?
He looks like a Kyrian old man.
He's literally Star Wars.
He's literally an old man.
Yeah!
He's just an old man on my back.
Goku, you're Luke Skywalker, but Goku.
I gotta see... Are you playing with pretty graphics on your game?
I'm playing on medium.
Oh, you're playing... I'm so jealous.
I play on, like, ugly, sweaty graphics.
So everything doesn't look as nice.
Let me do it again.
I know my place, so I can play medium.
There's no point in putting it on low.
I know there's no point in putting it on low.
I'm literally gonna get shit on no matter what.
Oh, your new model looks so good.
He's in his skin suit.
Oh, we're starting, we're starting.
Oh shit, yo, we're going in, we're going in.
Hey guys, is the volume a lot better now, chat, by the way?
My usual sound guy, he's at Evo right now, so...
Oh, what game is he playing at Evo?
I don't know.
I know he's like, that's why he's like, oh sorry, I can't do sound check.
Look at my Yoda, look at my Yoda.
Oh my god!
Wait, get rid of that crown, get rid of that crown.
Yeah, I got rid of it, I got rid of it.
Okay, you remember our Josh Plotter, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're pretty far from it.
Yeah, we're pretty far.
We got some time, we're chillin'.
We're chillin'.
Look at this battle bus, we're, like, literally vibing.
Okay, alright, don't worry.
I'm gonna adjust the sound now, guys.
Uh, sound effects, music, sound effects, alright.
That should be better now.
Alright, drop now.
Oh, just in time.
Yay!
Maybe you'll land a little short too?
Like, we have all this side, so we should be okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna land right here, but you should pop your parachute now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
My parachute is the dragon.
Oh, you're using the dragon?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm using fucking Nike kicks.
You have Nike, what?
Why?
I'm using Nike.
I see their fucking shoes.
Yeah, I am playing on 60 frames.
Why am I on 60 frames?
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, Yoda is laughing.
It is weirding me out right now.
Alright, let's see.
I'm grabbing the guns.
Oh my god, it's so weird seeing, like, all these footstep icons.
Yoda is really, really creeping me out.
Yoda is creeping me out just looking at him, staring at me.
No, he makes sounds.
He goes like...
Wait, does he actually?
Yeah.
That's fucking weird.
Yoda, that's fucking cringe.
Yoda, you got something cringe, dude.
Yeah, don't be cringe, Yoda.
We're trying to play a tournament right now.
I'm thinking of our croissant.
Yeah.
Wait, there's a...
There's a little crash thingy.
There's a plunger gun here.
Oh, that gun is so nasty.
You should get it.
No, you should use it.
You should...
It's hitscan.
No, it's hitscan.
It's so good.
That's a plunger gun.
No, that one?
No, the gun that you pinged?
Oh, that one.
Okay.
No, the one next to it?
The one next to it is nasty, though.
It's so good.
Oh, there's a gun next to it?
Oh!
Yeah.
That gun is so good.
Wait, I'll give it to you.
No, you should use it.
You know how to use this.
There's that?
And then...
Yeah, you use it.
I'll get the grappler.
No, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I don't know... I mean, I kind of know what I'm doing.
You don't even know what this gun is!
I was like, what the fuck is this gun?
I was like...
Alright, here, I'm going to splash this in.
Actually, no, you pop that big pot.
Okay.
Pop the big pot.
And then I'm going to finish looting this.
Alright, I'm drinking.
I'm sipping my thing.
Oh, we're in zone.
That's good.
Yeah, we're... Oh my god, we're hella in zone, too.
We're chillin'.
Okay, wait, I'm gonna...
How was I locked in 60?
What the fuck?
I didn't even realize.
Were you locked in 60?
Yeah, I was locked in 60.
I swear I, like, changed it.
I wonder if the settings actually reset for you.
I wasn't sure if it would, like, do it or not.
No, it, like, half reset.
So, like, I had to fix some of the stuff, but, like...
Yeah.
I remember changing it past 60.
Oh my god, we're so much more fluid now.
Okay, you see this, uh...
This is so weird.
You see this shield bubble?
Yeah.
That I just pinged?
Okay, like, did you ever play Halo back then?
Oh, actually, no, better yet, this is like a fucking Gibby bubble.
Oh!
You throw it at your feet, and it basically protects you.
Okay, that's good.
I think it's like 10 seconds.
There's another one there.
What gun is this?
Is that a rifle?
Yeah, they're all hitscan too.
Okay, that's good.
I have all jumping stuff.
Wait, we have to move again.
Oh, we have to go past Dusty.
Okay, so we can go over here.
We're gonna go towards the condo.
Whoa, we gotta do this.
Nice.
Yeah, we gotta do it for good luck.
Okay, where is it?
Where's my...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We're doing it for good luck, guys.
We need this.
We are also not the last team again, by the way.
Okay, nice.
We're not last.
That's all that matters.
We are not dead last.
Alright, let's go...
Yeah, I guess let's go down here.
I don't even have a shotgun.
This is terrible.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We're not last.
That's all that matters.
Just be thankful.
Let's see.
Is there...
Oh, we got movement.
Okay, sweet.
So, I have these jumpy pads that are...
Yeah, I have jump pads, too.
Oh, you have those, too?
Okay, okay.
Oh, in front of us?
I'm gonna back up real quick.
Whoa.
I'm gonna do this.
Pausing this.
Oh, god.
Wait, I got knocked already?
Oh, actually, I'm gonna bleed.
I'm gonna bleed.
I'm gonna bleed out.
Run away from me.
Run away.
Use the jumpy pad.
What the fuck?
No!
What?
Sam again!
The condom skins!
No!
I got shot before I could even see them.
Like, I was literally out of LOS, and I literally died because of ping around the corner.
Oh, no!
It's because they land next to us, so their condom men are always gonna be there.
Okay, now that I know they're gonna do that, I'm gonna literally play hyper-aggressive.
Like, I am confident I can definitely kill one of them.
I believe.
I believe in you.
Alright, don't worry.
Now we can talk strategy.
So the strat is gonna be that we literally kill these guys.
That is the strat.
No, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we gotta swap.
We didn't get a chance to use more of Dragon Ball Z, so we gotta keep going.
We gotta swap Dragon Ball Z characters.
Goku and Frieza just were not it.
They were raving a little too hard, but not hard enough.
Yeah, yeah.
We gotta do different Dragon Ball Z characters.
I have Cell, and you have Vegeta, right?
Yeah, I have Vegeta.
Alright, we'll go Vegeta and Cell.
We'll go Vegeta and Cell.
They're better than Goku and Frieza.
So seeing how this team is playing though, since they're...
I think usually what ends up happening, it's kinda like how Apex is.
We're like, once you get a feel for the team that lands next to your POI, they'll basically play off of that.
And the team knows that we're being very evasive.
So what we'll do is that we'll be ready for whatever angles they're gonna hold.
And we'll just play counter-aggressive on them.
Okay.
And if the zone ends up pulling where we have to run past them again, we can do a thing where we go towards the Loot Lake house on the island.
Yeah.
And then we can kinda rotate from there.
Okay.
And they're probably gonna either look for us from where we usually rotate, or they're just gonna not even mind us and go deal with the team to the right.
And I think that'll be the plan.
I think that'll be the plan.
I have no idea what you said, but I agree.
I'll just follow you.
Just nod your head and say yes.
Yeah.
And then we're like, yeah, yeah, yeah, we're good, we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, alright, from everything I heard from what you said, I just need to follow you.
Okay, I got that.
I understand.
I think what I should've probably did though, too, is just been like, oh, just, you know, give me bubble me if I go down.
Oh, that's true.
That's on me.
I didn't even like say any of that, so.
No, I'm pretty sure they would've killed us because they were there so fast.
They also had like, they had shockwaves ready for the moment they got a nod.
Yeah.
We just got unlucky on our way.
Picking your sweats, condiment.
What are these guys doing?
And you chose condiment.
Look at this team on top of the hill.
They're probably some very colorful Fortnite skins, and these guys are like, no, we're gonna eat a condom.
Fortnite made billions of dollars off of skin sales, and you decide to be condoms?
Condoms are, I guess, the new thing.
They're not even good skin.
They look so ugly.
Say it louder for the people in the back.
Is it because it's hard to see them?
Like, I don't understand.
Like, what's the appeal?
So, it's pretty much that.
It's like, if you're playing on like, ultra pretty graphics, it's harder to see them.
And then, also, it's like the, it's a very minimal, slim hitbox skin.
Wait, it affects the hitbox?
Yeah, so there are, I think it's like four different hitbox sizes in the game.
Wait, this is sweaty Wraith skin!
The reason why people play the bald Wraith is because it's a smaller hitbox.
Yup, yup, it's very much that, so...
It's a funny skin, it's pay to win!
Oh, these guys are gonna fight?
What the fuck is this tree?
Wait, you can grow a tree?
Wait, what?
Are they growing a tree?
What kind of condoms?
What?
They're gonna make love?
What the fuck?
You can grow trees?
Is this Mr. Beast?
Yo, what?
Mr. Beast growing trees?
Yeah, is this Mr. Beast growing the trees again?
You know they have a Mr. Beast skin, right?
Wait, did you see what happened to them?
You saw they got jumped?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they like fucking...
It's like what we almost did to them last game.
Oh, they're probably gonna die here!
They might die here.
Oh, no, no, wait, they're resetting?
Okay, so, you know how you respawn as long as one person is alive?
Yeah.
No, what I did was you can choose to bleed out very fast.
So that way it respawns you faster.
Oh!
So if you feel like it's just gonna be like a sucky situation, you can just say, Alright, I'm out, bye, and then just respawn.
Oh, but I have to live long enough.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
How do you keep growing trees?
Why are they still planting?
Is there Mr. Beast in a condom?
What was that Mr. Beast growing trees thing that he did?
Yeah, that was like...
What was it called?
I planted a bajillion trees in some country or whatever.
What was it called again?
Team Trees!
They're fucking Team Trees!
Yo, Team Trees?
Oh my god, I'm gonna burn some plastic to counteract this.
If you can plant trees in Fortnite, you should be able to burn plastic.
Oh my god.
Yo, yo, screw planting trees, you burn plastic outta here.
Yeah, yeah, it should be like the nerf to the tree thing.
In game guys, it's all, it's in game.
Aaron's like, why would you do that, Doki?
Like, if these guys are gonna plant trees, we just wanna burn the plastic in the game.
Yeah, we gotta burn the plastic to counteract all the trees that they're planting.
It's crazy.
For anyone wondering, the hitbox thing is a myth.
Oh no, that's true, that's true.
Cause like, I think there's like three or four body types in Fortnite?
I don't think it actually changes the hitbox.
Peter Griffin's definitely not the same hitbox as this.
Yeah, he's like...
There's no way.
Gigantic.
Oh, you know we could play?
Do you have the chicken?
I do have the chicken, I have the chicken.
You have the chicken, I have Peter!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yo, we could do the chicken and Peter.
Oh my god, we're gonna burn the chicken!
Okay, we gotta do it on like game four or something like that.
Unless we wanna do it next game.
No, no, no.
We'll do Peter the chicken next game, and then game four we'll bring back Dragon Ball.
Alright, I'm down, I'm down.
Someone's like, they're playing wide hitbox, they want to lose.
Oh, what do you mean that?
That's like the Gigachat move.
Everyone's gonna respect that.
They're gonna be like, oh, I do not wanna mess with the chicken and Peter Griffin.
They see our skins and they're just like, oh, they definitely don't know what they're doing.
We can definitely farm them.
Oh my god, I love how like coordinated everyone is with their jumps.
Holy shit, these guys are sweat.
No wonder my three Fortnite pro players fucking dodged me.
Wait, they're all condom skins!
Jesus!
It's 500!
Oh my god, they're all condom skins!
I love how like Fortnite compared to Apex is like the strats to a 1v1 fight is running in circles to get a right hand peek on someone.
That's literally Fortnite.
Oh my god, I would be the only one that's not running the skin.
Everyone's running some like condom skin and we're just like very, very colorful chickens.
They definitely know where to find us, that's for sure.
These look like NPCs fighting, they do.
They naturally do.
They look like NPCs.
They say, I don't wanna be the main character.
I'm just gonna be an NPC.
Oh my god, all reboots are disabled now.
Another condom?
Yeah, we're playing an attorney, so everyone I think wants to be a condom.
Yeah, everybody wants to be the condom players.
Please show me somebody that's not a condom!
Yeah, I'm gonna actually cycle through all the players.
Oh, I got someone who's not a condom!
Wait, who?
Who?
Uh, it's... who is this?
Oh my god, this guy!
Gene?
Wait, they're all like... they have the same skin!
Ew, there's another green condom.
Why are they all growing trees?
Oh, these are the like, OG sweatskins.
Oh wait, there's more!
Wait, can I cycle through the next one?
Is this like a fucking skill?
Why do some of them have trees growing or are they hiding in the trees?
Oh, these ones have like, cat ears?
Let's see...
Oh hey, this is green condom!
This one has green condom!
Whoa, these chicks are from the Witcher, I think.
Okay, so there's like, Witcher skins and then there's some like, cat ear skins that I can't find.
Oh my god, they're all the same skin!
Fucking beta male shit!
Why could you do fiend?
Be more fun!
Oh, condom's dead!
Fucking same skin?
That's so like, 2002.
Whatever happened to not being a condom?
I remember back in the good old days when no one wanted to be condoms.
They're growing trees again!
I'm gonna literally use that call out now because of you.
Yeah, I'm growing trees?
I'm growing trees?
Where's the individuality?
This is what like, the other players that bailed on you missed out on.
There's like, new call outs that no one else is gonna know.
Exactly.
You're just inventing new slangs.
I swear, it's not fair!
Like, why can't I burn plastic in Fortnite if I can grow trees?
Like, it should be perfectly balanced.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay, it's the Witcher skins again.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I respect this team.
Who is this?
Oh, they're all anonymous.
What the fuck?
I think these are Witcher skins.
Are these guys from Witcher?
All three of them are the same skin!
None of them are like different!
They're all actually the same skin!
Holy shit!
Everybody that's alive is wearing the same thing!
So boring.
This is why Fortnite is competitive instead.
I've been asked so many times, like, why don't I play competitive this game?
I'm like, I like playing this game in a very, very dumb manner.
I like it for all the giant toonie chicken skins.
Yeah!
Are you playing Fortnite competitive?
All you see are these dumb, dumb condom skins in different colors.
Then there's also, like, this is zero build, but everyone still builds ramps.
Because there's fucking... they should be able to remove items like Smash Brothers.
That's what I've always said.
I'm just like, yo, remove that shit!
Like, you know how, like, in competitive Apex, they remove, like, all the, uh, what is it called?
The... the heat shields?
Yeah, yeah, the heat shields, yeah.
The heat shields are removed?
But Portal Bunkers should be removed!
In competitive!
I'm pretty sure they are modifiable, but, like, I think they just leave them because they want it to be, like, how it is in the regular mode?
I don't know.
Yeah, they couldn't... Fortnite could... can have even more... Fortnite competitive can have more sponsors.
And they force all of them to wear, like, funny skins.
No, I would do that tournament in a heartbeat.
They're like, no, no sweat skins, no matching skins.
You have to be all different.
Yeah, everybody... you know how, like, you gotta claim your drop spot?
You gotta claim your skin.
Each person has to have a different skin, so you gotta claim whichever skin you're wearing.
Yo... yo, okay, I think you're cooking right now.
I think you're actually cooking.
You are cooking something, Doki.
Is this the next tournament that's gonna happen?
Like, I would actually do a tournament like that.
That would be so fucking fun.
That's, like, literally free advertisement with, like, for the other pieces.
Like, imagine, like, the person wearing the weakened skin won, like, a million dollar Fortnite bucks.
Like, and then, like, you know, the weakened get, like, free advertisement.
And then, like, and then people be like, well, I want to wear the weakened skin.
And then people, and then all the little kitties are gonna buy the weakened skin even more.
Yo... okay, okay, no, no, no.
On the real, okay, I'm, like, I'm even thinking, what if you do that and, like, you force everyone to not use any of these items, right?
Like, it's all, like, just movement items.
All, like, things that just add more chaos to the mix.
That would be so stupid fun.
That would be so fun.
Just, you know, just remove all items in general.
Just...
The thing is, the reason why they need this is because Fortnite is so, such an open map in general.
They don't have enough cover.
And, like, Apex or, and, like, Apex and other FPS games, maps are designed to have cover.
Fortnite is designed to not have cover because they expect you to make your cover.
Yeah, so zero build players just go through it.
They need to have the bunkers.
The diet bunkers.
They need the bunkers.
Look at this nerd, he downed himself.
My water's still...
Oh!
Condom dead!
A non-condom team won!
Yeah!
We had a non-condom team!
Yeah, but they have the same skin, don't they?
Are they wearing the same skin together?
I think they are, yeah.
No!
Oh, they're gonna win!
It's like, it's okay.
As long as, as long as there's no condom winners, we all win.
They go against the meta!
They go against the meta, that's all that matters.
Okay, I put Peter Griffin on.
Alright, I'm putting the chicken on.
It's time to be a chicken.
Alright.
Let's see what dance, is there any cool dances on?
On the store?
Oh, yeah, let me, let me actually change...
It's time to shop.
My emotes.
Wait, do you have Batman later?
Do you have Batman?
Wait, Batman?
Yeah, do you have Batman?
The skin?
Or like the emote?
Yeah, the skin.
No, no, I don't have Batman.
No!
Okay, because I have the Batman who laughs.
Oh, that skin's sick!
Okay, actually...
Wait, I have Mr. Beast!
I bought Mr. Beast!
Oh my god!
I forgot it was in the store!
I was like, I gotta have Mr. Beast.
Oh my god.
Wait, if we find the trees, I wanna be Mr. Beast and plant the trees.
I don't care if we die, I just wanna plant some trees.
Wait, if you were to play...
Okay, one of these rounds, we have to do Mr. Beast and someone else.
Who would I be?
Who would you be?
Chat, who would match with Mr. Beast?
Who would match Mr. Beast, guys?
I'm like watching him dance right now.
Nia?
Uh, wait.
Is there another YouTuber?
Is there another YouTuber skin that you have?
Uh, let me see, let me see.
Uh, there is...
Oh, I guess I could be like Cabbie Lane.
Uh, the guy who does the shrug?
You know, he's really big on TikTok.
He does the shrugging all the time.
Oh my god, Peter.
Oh my god, I'm looking at like the different emotes.
Like the emotes that I could get.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, wait, I need to buy this.
Give me a sec, I'm gonna hide my screen.
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
I need to buy this, guys.
Okay, I'm gonna equip.
Nice.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh my god, he's fucking spreading it.
Oh my god.
I have so many anime skins.
Wait, wait, show me the other YouTuber.
The other YouTuber?
Um...
Yeah.
Dang, I...
He's partially on YouTube.
He's like more TikTok, but...
This guy.
Oh, wasn't he like banned on YouTube?
Wait, did he get banned on YouTube?
I remember he like got banned somewhere.
It was a Twitter.
Oh, I know, I know.
Oh, I don't know.
Wait, how the fuck did he get any...
How did he...
How did he get a Fortnite skin?
I don't know, I'm just a wolf.
I just work here.
Bro, somebody must really...
Somebody at Fortnite must really, really like this guy.
Just don't expect him to get a Fortnite skin.
Wait, what other guys do they have?
Let's see, do I have another YouTuber?
I'm going through all these.
I don't know if I have another...
I mean like I might have like a gamer YouTuber, but I don't have like...
I'm like MrBeast.
Watch this, look who I got.
Wait, who you got?
Wait, what do I buy?
Look at him go.
Yo, I have the emote.
I have that one, I have that one.
You have the emote?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, did you get the new code?
Oh, we just got a new code.
Oh, okay.
Bom, bom, bom, bom, bom.
Did you guys hear that chat?
The bot killer.
Oh yeah, I should...
No one is ready.
I should change some of my emotes too.
Emotes.
Okay, what do I...
I want to keep the Macarena.
Oh, Christmas tree skin for MrBeast.
Let's see.
Oh, that's true, you should be a tree.
You should be a tree.
Yeah, I can be a tree.
I have a Christmas tree.
Okay, I need...
Where's the...
What's that emote called again?
Which one?
The one you were just doing.
That's the Master of Puppets.
Oh, Master of Puppets, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It should be at the top.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the fucking...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I got it, I got it.
I gotta make sure this is in there.
You have it?
Okay, let's go.
Look at the guitar, it's like out of his skin.
His body is so fucking massive.
It's so fucking big.
Oh my god.
I'm winning in spirit.
Go!
Look at his giant toony eyes.
What the fuck?
How many emotes do you have?
I have way too many.
You don't even want to know how many I have.
Oh wait, that's the witchy.
Which one?
This one?
No, the bathtub.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is that the witchy?
Oh, is that from The Witcher?
Is it?
Does he take a bath?
Yeah, he takes a bath in that thing.
Yeah.
I had no idea.
Oh my god, I was so concerned.
I thought that was the witchy.
This is...
He has a little truck.
Yay, beep beep.
Beep beep.
Oh my god, I clipped in the chair.
I think you're gonna die first.
But I will never...
Holy shit, you have so...
Wait, how do you scroll through more?
Oh, there's more pages.
Yeah, I got the classic.
I have way too many pages.
Oh my god, I got the classic.
Oh, wait, I didn't win round two.
Guiltiest way...
Okay, not that.
What is that?
It's in a type on tiny mode.
It's the AOT one.
Wait, what's the other one?
What is that?
It looks so terrifying.
It's a silly bird.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, these all look so good.
Do you have Futurama?
What the fuck is that?
Is that...
What is that?
What is that for?
I think it's a DC.
It's a DC co-op.
Oh, it's from one of the DC comics.
I have Dead Space.
What the fuck?
I'm in the classic Fortnite.
Yo, the classic one.
We gotta do the classic.
Yeah.
Wait, where do I have that one?
Oh, hey, Gumi.
Yeah, I just love Fortnite emotes.
Oh, wait, I have this.
Wait, no, I have this.
Wait, where the fuck did I get this?
Oh, Black Adam.
That's what it is.
Is that Kung Fu Panda?
Oh my god, I get to look at Kung Fu Panda.
I think it's supposed to be...
There's like a master Sifu skin or something.
Nuh-uh.
They have so many things in this game.
That's why I keep making this game serious.
Wait, did we get it?
Did we get it?
Did we get missed?
Oh, no, we got it.
Wait.
Oh, no, no, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good.
I couldn't help it.
Look at all these cool emotes.
Oh, we just made it.
We just made it.
They're like, we're missing one duo.
Who could it be?
Nami!
Here, here, here.
Emo with me, emo with me.
Yeah!
Yeah, join us!
Wait!
What?
It's gone!
Why'd they bring us?
Yeah, no!
Jeff!
It's not even Christmas, lady.
Okay.
Tell me when to drop.
All right, all right.
We're good about now.
All right, we're good.
All right, guys, I increased the game volume more.
I'm going to land right here.
I hope the volume's better now.
We're so locked in, guys.
We're locked in.
We are locked in.
No one even knows how locked in we are.
Yeah, we're so locked in.
Yeah.
This is the skin that will make us be like, we haven't been last yet, guys.
We're so locked in.
There's another team that is losing before us, and that's all that matters.
And it's not us.
Oh, I got a shotgun.
All right, we're good.
We're good.
Nice.
All right, I'm about to be done looting.
Drinking some stuff.
Oh, the chest is space now.
That's cool.
There's a llama over here.
Oh, it's so risky for me to go for that.
Okay, I'm going to go to you.
I'm going to you.
Oh, I got the same thing.
Wait, J3?
We're doing better than J3?
That's right.
That's what you get for having two Overwatch players.
Oh, is that an Overwatch player?
Yeah, they're both Overwatch players.
Oh, I did not know that.
Their team is literally the Overwatch team.
That's what you get.
Do we get counted as Apex players?
I don't know.
One at a time?
I don't know what they count.
They count me as the person from YouTube that they're bringing over.
I'm just the trusty sidekick, the V2 werewolf chicken.
The chicken.
You're the Fortnite bodyguard.
To make sure I don't die first.
I'm going to bodyblock with my giant, sweet chicken meat.
Yeah, you got to make sure you're not last.
That's it.
I'm the exchange student.
Yeah, I'm the exchange student.
What is this?
What gun is this?
I don't know.
Oh, it's an infantry rifle.
Which is...
Actually, really, really good.
I have one too.
You can splash us.
And then you can splash us one more time.
Yay!
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
Alright, so...
Now that we're kind of on zone, we can watch out for this team.
Or we can just keep rotating north.
We can go over here.
Alright.
It's your pick.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
Let's rotate right now.
Okay, I'm going to go down on the...
Actually...
It's kind of a scary rotate because we kind of got to go out in the open.
Yeah.
It is pretty scary.
Do you have any, like, protection at all?
Before we get pushed?
I have...
I have the shockwave grenade.
Oh, you have the shockwave.
Okay, you saw how it works, right?
Okay, I'm going to give you my shockwave grenades.
No, you don't want that.
I don't think I can do the things they were doing.
Okay, we can literally chill inside here.
Or we can keep on moving towards...
Wait, can we...
Let's see.
Oh my god, we can't go into the bathroom?
We can't hide in the bathroom?
What we could do is we could chill here and wait.
Oh yeah, okay.
So we're going to have to keep on rotating.
We can keep going this way.
So I'm going to go outside.
Keep on following me.
Hey, I'm following.
Okay, okay, okay.
It's okay.
Did anyone die yet, guys?
Nobody's dead yet?
One team has died.
One team died.
Oh, good.
Yeah, we're not dead last.
Okay, good.
That's great.
That's what I like to hear.
Oh my god.
Wait, the Overwatch player is dying.
Yeah!
Oh my god, that's great.
That's great to know.
We can hide here in the bush.
Oh my god, we can be bushmen too.
Wait, what's up?
What's up?
I'm going to crouch.
Wait, they probably know.
I'm going to move to the left.
Can I get an angle?
Yeah, they're on rooftop.
They don't...
Oh, they know.
They are at...
Looping?
Okay.
Are they looking at us or...?
They know that we're here.
They're rotating.
Okay.
Oh my god, I can see the...
Day one.
Almost cracked one.
Oh my god, they're planting trees again!
Let's go left.
How did I keep getting the trees?
I'm going to throw on the side.
I'm good now.
I'm good.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm going to do this.
I'm doing this.
Oh, god.
I'm not good.
We're good.
We can go inside here.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, just watch yourself.
And then, uh, let's see.
Let me actually get an angle to, like, try and shoot them.
They're still on the rooftop.
Okay.
We can keep moving to the next house over.
So, let's go outside here.
And I'm going to start rotating.
We are safer now.
All these minis here are huge.
I feel safer inside.
I think we can move over to the next house.
Alright.
I'm going to, uh, see.
Should I break the wall?
Okay, we're going to go with the back door like we did the last house.
Okay, let's go now.
Thank you, Fortnite bodyguard.
You're welcome.
Other Fortnite bodyguard.
Alright, we're chilling.
We're chilling here.
We're good.
Protect me, Fortnite bodyguard.
Alright, we get to just hang out here until the next...
Oh, they're in the bush.
Oh, they're bush people.
How can you be a bush person if you're not Mr. Beast?
I know, right?
These guys are...
How could you?
Oh, wait.
Okay, I don't know if there's anyone below us.
There's footsteps.
I'm going to actually just move around.
I'm going to make noise.
They're on the other house.
Get away!
This is our house!
Watch your back here.
Because they could shoot you in the back.
Okay.
But they're rotating away.
I hear you.
Yeah, I hear them.
I think they might want to fight.
I'm below.
They should get shot on the top.
What are you doing?
I have my shotgun too!
Okay, so you know how the shockwaves work, kind of, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If they push you guys, don't feel bad to shockwave yourself carelessly.
Okay.
If you shockwave me into the storm, that's okay, because I can shockwave myself another direction.
So, just play selfishly if they end up trying to push you.
They're waiting for an opportunity to jump us, so I'm just watching around.
Yeah, that's right.
I have my bodyguard here.
It's a fucking dog.
Is there a rooftop?
Okay.
Oh, wait, they're getting shot at.
Are they?
Wait, no, they fell, they fell.
Wait, are they rotating?
They might be rotating.
I think they're rotating.
Yeah, they're rotating.
Okay, okay.
Okay, so, we're going to have to rotate.
Let me see what's available.
I think, is that in?
Alright, so we're going to go out the back again.
And we're going to, okay, I want you to slide run onto...
Fuck, through that.
Oh, team on our side, on the right side.
I see them, I see them.
Almost cracked them.
Cracked, almost cracked the other two.
I'm going to, we're going to shockwave to the other house over here.
Okay.
So, just get away from me, get away from me, get away from me.
And then I'm going to shockwave.
I'm going now.
And I'm going to launchpad.
And go this way.
I'm looking for you, I'm looking for you.
You're good.
You're good, Toki.
I'm looking for you, I'm looking for you.
I'm over here, I'm over here.
You're good.
Yo, you're good.
I did it.
Yo, we're good.
Okay, we're in the next zone, we're in the next zone.
We're in the next zone, we're chilling, we're chilling.
There's also a...
There's a Gibby bubble right here as well.
Okay, yeah, yeah, I can take it.
Oh, we're also in the next zone too, we're in the next zone too, we're chilling.
Oh thank god, oh thank god, I'm going to be hiding in the bunker.
The fallout's coming, I'm going to hide in the bunker.
I think we forced that team to rotate onto another team, so we're good, we're good for now.
Okay, I'll stay here.
I think I'm going to get onto...
Someone killed the Overwatch squad already, so at least I can be better than the Overwatch people.
That's all I want.
I cracked one in Storm, but they're eating a lot of damage over here, so I'm going to keep pressure on them.
I think I'm actually okay up here.
I'm worried.
We have this whole house.
Okay.
I'm so scared of peeking though.
Yeah, no, you can chill inside, you can chill inside.
Okay, okay, I'm looking into... I'm looking here.
Are we still in zone?
Yeah, we're still in zone.
The team that you're shooting, are they still in zone?
Yeah, they're still out in the blue right now.
I think they rotated to the water side.
Are you getting shot at?
No, did you hear that?
That was an RPG.
Oh, what?
They're shooting RPGs at us.
It was like...
I was like, what the fuck was that?
I think this guy went over here.
Oh, thank God the Overwatch duo is dead.
We're vibing right now.
We're not vibing as much anymore.
That is so far.
We have the beach that we can play on.
What the fuck?
Let's see, what can we actually play here?
I'm going to kind of look out for a spot that we can get to.
Is that in?
Oh, that is very in.
Okay, we can get to that rock there, I think.
There's also a team play.
I have another shock if you want one.
How many do you have?
Oh, you do?
No, keep it for yourself because I have launch pads.
We're going to go with the zone very, very last second.
You know how the crash pads work?
Okay, just slide crouch onto it.
I'm going to burn some right now.
Okay, we're going to try to get to my blue ping.
Let me go now.
We're going to go here.
I'm going to chill here for a sec.
Oh, what's in here?
Wait, did I get shot?
Okay, no.
No, we're good.
We're going to do a slow rotate.
We're going to be little babies.
Is that team on the porta bunker right there?
Don't blow yourself up.
Oh my god, I see you.
You're good.
I don't feel good.
I might be dead.
They're like in the ocean.
I was so confused.
They're over there.
Wait, can I reboot?
Oh, I might be dead.
No, don't die!
I can reboot!
No!
I might have been able to res you.
Oh, you're still alive?
No, I died.
No!
I was so confused.
I was like, what was that?
What was shooting me?
He's hiding in the fucking bush!
I got shot.
No one expects them to be in the water!
Fortnite moment.
No!
It's okay.
We did better.
We did not die in dead last.
We were 15th?
Yeah, and we didn't die to the condom people.
I died to the condom on height, but you didn't die to the water people.
At least one of us is better, I guess.
No, I died to a condom.
It's over.
You died to a condom person.
I can't believe it.
What the fuck is going on here?
We actually did really good there, though.
Look, we got our synergy down.
Yeah, we're getting better and better.
We're getting better placements.
Yeah.
We got 15th, 16th, and we don't talk about the other one, but 15th and 16th.
That's pretty good.
That's really good.
That's really, really good.
I'm proud of us.
Against all these other Fortnite gamers, that's pretty.
And no matter what, we win money.
No matter how well we do, everybody wins money.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
How many bunkers is this one?
Is the entire loot just bunkers?
Okay, so I've been playing Reloaded with a bunch of friends lately.
And my biggest complaint is literally the fact that bunkers exist.
Because it turns into this, but in casual too.
It feels like they have like 20 houses.
I know, right?
Yeah.
When you play quads, it's literally like fortresses that you're going against.
How many houses can you carry?
It's four per stack.
You can carry four houses?
This guy must have like eight or some shit.
There's no fucking way.
I literally saw him build like four different houses, and he still had houses.
He still has bunkers!
He still has another bunker?!
This guy doesn't realize that he's going to break his bush.
He broke his bush!
No!
And he still has a house!
So your reactions are filling me with life.
Because that is all of my reactions when I first started playing Fortnite.
And it still is the same.
What the fuck is like the real estate market in Fortnite?
They're going to burst a bubble?!
How many houses does he have?!
Wait, which guy are you watching?
I'm watching this like JF guy.
I don't know.
He's either JF or The Anonymous.
I'm expecting Anonymous264, because this guy has like fucking Anonymous mode on.
But his team is like JF or something on Twitch.
Yeah, his teammate has like 200,000 houses.
Every fucking time he wants to advance or run away, he has a fucking house.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah, I'm watching JF right now.
You see all those houses around you?
He built all those houses.
He built this.
Maybe he's MrBeast.
It might actually be him.
Oh my god, he's the MrBeast that builds houses.
Last game was the MrBeast that could plant trees.
This one fucking builds houses.
Oh my god, that's the RPG I heard.
Yeah, that was the RPG I heard.
Oh, it's the Christmas chicks.
Or the Christmas hats.
Oh my god.
Oh, does he have another house?
I swear to god.
If he throws another fucking house down, I swear...
Okay, this is why us FPSers cannot main Fortnite.
I swear to god.
The meta is literally you turn into a house.
That's the meta.
I swear to fucking god.
I swear it's so easy to find houses too.
Oh my god, please someone kill him!
Oh thank god.
He was ruining the economy.
Oh my god, they're fully dead.
Thank god.
His teammate had a house that he was about to throw.
I saw him.
I saw him hold the fucking port-a-bunker.
He was like, I'm ready for it.
I'm gonna grow a house again.
I saw the port -a -bunker in his fucking hand.
I'm not watching condom men.
I'm gonna watch somebody else.
Wait, wait, there's Christmas people in the house right now.
Yeah, yeah, I'm watching the Christmas people.
Jesus Christ, they're getting their house being destroyed.
Oh my god.
It's okay, they're fine.
They also built their own house.
Oh my god, they built two houses!
Aww, they have three more houses in their inventory too.
Yo, that's cute though.
Oh my god.
The housing market is going crazy.
That's four houses.
That's four fucking port-a-bunkers.
He has a big one right there.
That's five.
Does he have another one?
Oh, there's six!
He's complaining about not having a house anymore.
Oh, there's seven!
Oh, and he goes down!
Don't worry, throw another one down!
Eight!
Nine!
This one team threw nine houses in 30 seconds, I swear.
And he had another one in his head!
Yo, you are my inner monologue.
I fucking love you so much.
He had ten houses in his head!
Finally,
30 seconds!
And he's like, oh, you can hold four.
This man's entire inventory was literally just port-a-bunkers.
He had nothing else.
Oh my god.
Alright, these are the new comms.
I'm literally using Yoki comms from now on.
I am not using any more of the comms that I've acquired throughout my time playing.
Did this guy even have guns?
I'm just gonna call it growing a house.
There's no way!
I think that guy that was watching had literally one gun and the other four spots were port-a-bunkers.
Oh, the condom Gibby bubbled!
He's doing a temporary house.
Oh, they're making boobs!
They made boobs!
I literally saw it!
Look, they're doing it again!
Oh, they're making houses again.
Yeah, it's boobs and houses now.
That's the meta.
Oh, he blew the condom away!
That was actually a really good play.
He recycled them.
Oh, wait, wait.
He's gonna grow a house on him.
Oh no, he blew him out!
That's so smart!
How many fucking what?
Oh, his teammate's dead.
His teammate got a two-copy.
Oh my god, yes, don't have to try this hard.
You're gonna be in day two anyway.
Oh, the condoms are dead!
It's a 1v1, it's a 1v1.
He's dead.
Oh, another condom.
Yeah.
Three games.
Wait, what?
There's more?
Oh, I thought there was another team.
Chat's like, do we need to show Doki the port-a-fortresses?
Wait, when did... Oh, the Christmas... There's another Christmas team.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, there is more.
Oh yeah, look, there's like a white one and a red one.
Yeah, it's 1v2, it's 1v2 now.
What the fuck?
These guys third-partied!
I was like, where did these guys come from?
Oh?
Wait, what?
Where's the other team?
Are these healing?
Is he just healing in the storm?
Oh my god, I like how it's still like... a build-mode heal-off.
Oh no, he's... Yeah, he couldn't heal from that.
He's dead-dead.
They won.
Oh, thank god.
I'm glad it's not...
Doki, the people's winner.
Or the people's choice won.
We didn't have condoms win.
Oh my god, thank god.
Two of the four games were not from the condoms.
That's all that matters.
The games were not completely cursed.
They were not cursed.
Yeah, yeah.
They were slightly, slightly cursed.
Wait, this is... Two out of three.
That's great.
That means like...
They tried so hard to be sweaty, but only one condom team won.
That's all I wanted.
Game number...
Game four.
Yeah, yeah.
Are we gonna do Mr. Beast or Dragon Ball Z?
Um... I'm down for Dragon Ball again.
Or do you wanna do... No, let's switch it up.
Let's do Mr. Beast.
Alright.
I was gonna say it was gonna be Capulet.
We're gonna be a tree.
Oh, yeah.
Tree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Let's see.
And I'll have Mom's Spaghetti on my backpack.
Wait, no.
I should have like... Gough.
Cause he's Mr. Beast.
I bet he loves golfing.
Oh my god, but he could be the people's champion.
I'm gonna be the tree!
I'm trying to figure out my backpack.
Wait, what is the tree's name?
Christmas?
No?
Uh...
I know I have them here.
I could also be a big giant corn.
Oh, I could have!
Wait, I'm gonna... I'm gonna put... I'm gonna put a pizza delivery in my backpack.
Maybe Mr. Beast is delivering pizza.
I have an Amogus, but I could also put a... Actually, what would Mr. Beast put on the Christmas tree?
Oh, what would he put on the Christmas tree?
Do you have money?
Uh... I might have money.
I think I have a money bag.
Hold on, where's the money bag?
If you have money, we could put money in the backpack.
It would make sense!
Yeah!
I'm gonna use pom-poms too.
That's right, okay.
A briefcase.
I think I have a briefcase.
A briefcase full of money, let's go.
We're gonna be planting some trees, let's go.
Uh... I think that one might be okay.
Oh, is there one with money, like, that's pouring out of it, Jack?
Okay, that one's fine.
Okay, we're using that.
We're using that.
And then... Oh, what are you using for your pickaxe?
Oh, my pickaxe?
I'm using pom-poms.
Oh, I have the pom-poms too!
Yeah, let's both have pom-poms.
Alright, pom-poms.
MrBeast is gonna cheer us on.
Yeah, we're gonna go plant some trees, guys.
Today, we're gonna be planting a hundred thousand trees.
Alright, what glider do I use?
I guess I'll just use...
Oh, no, I have a money bag one, I forgot.
It's actually money, like, flowing in the sky.
Oh, my God, that's so good!
Wait, that's perfect!
Yeah, do you have that one too?
No, I don't.
Yeah, but that's perfect.
Uh, I'll do the banana.
Wait, I have bling!
Wait, is that bling?
No, here's rockets.
What is this?
Skyscratch.
What is that?
What the fuck is that?
Let's see, I'll still use... Ooh, diamond!
Wait, when did you start playing the game?
I feel like we have a lot of the same Battle Pass stuff.
I have no idea.
I, like, play it on and off.
That was me this season.
When the season first started, I was like, okay, I'm definitely not playing this car game.
Too real.
Wait, maybe if they have, like... Do they have any money-related trails?
I have a staircase.
Ooh, go, Mr. Peace, go!
Go support the trees, Mr. Peace!
And cure the blind!
You got this!
I'm gonna buy this, actually.
I'll do that.
The money bag item is called Goldilocks.
Oh, I have that.
Goldilocks.
No, I don't have it.
I bought a really good emote.
Alright.
Guys, if you guys want to support me so I can buy more... more cosmetics...
Use DokiBird and support a creator.
And then you keep that.
Use code DokiBird.
Use code DokiBird so we can buy more pretty cosmetics.
Alright, this is... I bought a new dance emote.
You wanna see?
Yeah, yeah, do it, do it, do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's see, where is it?
Oh my god, where did I buy it?
Did you just get it in the shop right now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I just got it.
I wanna see if I can find it from regular scrolling.
Is it glitter?
No!
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I bought glitter.
Oh, I love that one!
Wait, did you just buy it?
No, I have that one in my inventory right now.
Okay, wait, wait.
I just gotta find it.
Yeah, I need to find glitter.
Wait, it's called glitter.
Alright, there it is.
Go, Mr. Peace!
Okay.
Where is it?
Where's my main inventory for emotes?
Oh, there it is.
Go, Mr. Peace, go!
Plant those trees!
Show the world that you can be the next president of America!
You see this tree here?
I planted that!
You see that?
I planted that tree!
I'm Mr. Peace!
Save the world!
Every day we get closer and closer.
And also, lock 100 people into a supermarket battle royale style!
That's what they want!
But woo!
We cured the blind!
I planted houses in Fortnite!
Yeah!
Oh, we got the new code.
Don't worry!
Let me throw money at you!
But first, you gotta do this grueling 10-hour obstacle course if you wanna want that money, though!
And then I'm gonna give you V-Bucks!
Woo!
V-Bucks!
And then you're gonna buy things in the video game using code Mr. Peace, and then I'm gonna cure you!
Yeah!
Alright,
cool.
I'm gonna get ready up for real this time.
I'm gonna run the bathroom real quick.
I will BRV, because I've been needing to pee.
Maybe after you pee, you'll get better, too.
I feel like that's gonna happen.
I'm gonna exhaust all of my bad skills.
Yeah, the moment you pee, you'll become a better player.
It's happening.
Alright, BRV!
BRV chat!
Alright, see you later!
Guys, do you guys think we're gonna do better?
Guys, every game we're getting a little bit better, you know?
As long as we're better than the Overwatch people, that's all that matters to me.
As long as...
We're better than the Overwatch team.
That's all that matters.
And also, yeah, we can only go up from here.
And I bet you, we are the team that's having the most fun!
I bet you, nobody else is having just as much fun as we are, because that's all we have.
Like, we know our place in this tournament.
As long as we're having fun, that's all that matters.
True.
If we don't have fun, what else can we do?
What else do we have?
We have six matches.
This is four, so we have three more games.
Where's the aimbot?
Guys, you know damn well that I'm not pulling up the aimbot.
I think I shot my gun, like, one time.
We've only shot our gun one time.
I know my place.
I'm just here to spend money on Fortnite and do silly dances.
That's what you need.
I'm here to dance!
Yes, I landed one!
The one shot I landed...
The one shot...
The one shot I landed, it hit.
And that's all that mattered.
That's right!
Flex it, Mr. Beast!
Flex it!
Yeah, why shoot gun when everybody builds a fucking house?
We're out here trying to find houses to live in.
Everybody else is just building houses.
How did they find all those port-a-bunkers?
Like, that's what I'm confused about.
How does one drop spot have 200 fucking port-a-bunkers?
I don't understand.
When will I have my Fortnite skin?
Guys...
Guys, would you like...
Want me to have...
Would you guys like...
Spend at least $100,000 on Fortnite if I have my skin on there?
Maybe that's how what it takes.
No.
Guys, this is exactly why I don't have a Fortnite skin!
I need commitment!
Commitment!
I need commitment here!
I mean, maybe.
Guys, I need some commitment here.
I need to have a Fortnite skin.
Dude, I don't even give...
Okay, how many Fortnite players have they given skins to?
Okay, Fortnite skins of Fortnite players.
Other than Ninja.
Is there actual Fortnite skins for actual Fortnite...
Okay, not like I'm saying Ninja isn't a Fortnite player.
Quite a lot?
Wait, really?
Okay, I'm looking.
Okay, they have Ninja.
They have Travis Scott.
I forgot about that.
All the time?
Oh, you're right!
I see Loserfruit there!
Wait, you're right!
Guys, I need you guys to spend $100,000.
I'm going to shoot Fortnite an email and be like...
I mean, if like... What's his name?
The... Kabi... Lame?
Lame?
What's his name?
The guy that shrugs.
If he gets a Fortnite skin...
Oh, because he has 81 million followers on Instagram.
That makes a lot more sense now.
Guys, this guy...
He has 81 million followers.
He has a video with Will Smith?
Guys, I don't have...
Welcome back, Doryu.
Wait, what are we talking about?
I heard Will Smith.
Let's talk about that YouTube skin you have.
What's his name?
Oh, Kabi Lame?
Yeah, Kabi Lame.
I was like, if he can have a Fortnite skin, I should have one.
But then I looked him up and he has 81 million followers on Instagram.
And I was like...
I was just like...
That is insane.
That's why.
I had no idea he had that much...
That's crazy.
That's so cool.
People in my chat was like, who's that guy?
I was like, this guy did a fucking video with Will Smith.
Where's my Will?
And they're like, where's your Will Smith collab?
I don't fucking know.
Wait, when did you collab with Will Smith?
Will Smith answered my DMs.
That's gonna be such a wild collab if you ever play with him or Kabi Lame.
Do you even think Kabi Lame plays Fortnite?
Does he play Fortnite?
Wait, is that why he got a Fortnite skin?
I don't know.
Do you think Eminem plays Fortnite?
Because Eminem also has a skin too in the game.
Well, Eminem doesn't play Fortnite.
He's just there for his music.
I mean, do you think Lady Gaga plays Fortnite?
I think Lady Gaga did play Fortnite.
Wait, does Lady Gaga play Fortnite?
I think...
Wait, no.
She has to have.
There's no way.
She has like three skins in the game.
She has three skins?
Lady Gaga has three.
Why does Lady Gaga need three skins in Fortnite?
Lady Gaga has like, I think, two variants.
And then, I think she might have like one that you can change.
Like a different variant.
There's no way.
Wait, she fucking tweeted out about Fortnite.
Wait, two years ago today, Lady Gaga kicked...
Oh wait, no, that's just somebody's like Lady Gaga Fortnite account.
I was like, oh my god, did Lady Gaga tweet about Fortnite?
But no.
She also has 170 million TikTok followers?
Oh, for Cabbie?
Yeah, I know about that.
Bro, Brandon Urie plays Fortnite.
He used to be a Twitch streamer.
Dang.
Oh, I made sure to hydrate.
Wait, did I ready up?
I did, okay.
Okay, Fortnite skin.
Does Brandon Urie have...
Brandon Urie doesn't even have a Fortnite skin.
If anybody deserves a Fortnite skin, it's Brandon Urie.
Wait, who's Brandon Urie?
Brandon Urie, he did the...
He did like the...
He's Panic at the Disco.
Oh, wait, what?
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Yeah, he streams Fortnite.
I've seen him stream Fortnite.
Dang.
I don't know if he still streams it.
I see there's like some singers who actually have...
Like, time in the game.
I know that...
Oh, who was it?
There's like another singer recently.
Who was like doing a lot of clips.
Because she streamed after Lady Gaga's skin came out.
Oh.
That's interesting.
Wait, where do we go?
Let's get it, Donkey!
Let's fucking go!
We're gonna survive extra long again.
Okay, that's good.
We actually rotated really fucking good last game.
Yeah, we did really good rotate.
When will we get middle of the zone?
This is not good.
We can drop now.
I know, right?
Wait, I don't think it's possible for us to get middle of the zone because we're at the side.
When will we get like...
No, I can pull.
I can pull over here for sure.
Yeah, where's our pull?
I wanna live in this house right here.
Are you being nice and cozy in there?
Yeah.
There's so many gliders?
I wanna plant a tree.
We haven't got a single tree.
Oh, I will call the trees and we're gonna...
I mean like I'm a walking tree, but planting one just hits diff, you know?
Alright.
Yeah, tree planting a tree.
That's all we wanted.
Oh, I got the shocking thing.
Let's see.
Please don't shoot me.
Why would they shoot you?
They would never shoot a tree, right?
Yeah.
They would never shoot you.
Wait, I found a tree!
Found one!
Let's go!
I got the tree!
Tree meta!
It's over.
It's fucking over.
I can't believe it.
It's as MrBeast that I found the tree.
It's like...
I found two trees!
Oh my...
It's so fucking over.
I literally found two trees.
Your personal walking tree is running up to you right now.
Oh my god.
The MrBeast buff.
I had zero trees going in for the last three games.
And then on the fourth game, when I decided to be MrBeast, I find the tree.
It was meant to be.
It was!
It's like MrBeast was meant to be a tree.
Is this...
Oh no, it's a shield bubble.
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of this then.
See, I have the plunger.
The plunger?
Oh, you have the plunger and also have the pistol.
Oh, you got the pistol too?
Yeah.
Oh, huge.
Oh, open that chest.
It's a blue.
Oh, that's what you need.
It's a pump.
Oh my god, it's a bunker!
You should have it.
Do you have one?
You don't want the shotgun?
No, no, no, no, no.
I would not be using that.
What?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
And then you wanna grow houses?
You saw the houses work, right?
Yeah.
Should I grow houses?
If you wanna grow trees, what do you feel like?
I have shield.
Okay, shield or...
I'll grow...
I'll give you the shield.
I'll grow a house.
Alright.
I build a house and I plant trees.
The houses belong in this universe's inventory.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's immersive.
Well, there's more trees here.
There's more trees here.
Oh my god, there's all the trees!
Yeah, we got so many trees here.
Oh my god, you know what?
I don't need shockwave grenade.
I'll have...
Wait, maybe I do.
Maybe I'm getting a bit too overconfident here.
No, no, no, no, no.
Let the confidence out.
Let the confidence...
Wait, this is our time to shine.
You know what?
I don't need guns.
Wait, we gotta heal you.
I'm so dumb.
I did not realize I popped a big.
Wait, you don't have any shields.
It's okay.
I don't need...
I don't need a...
I don't need a gun.
I need one gun.
Is there minis here?
Uh, can you...
Oh my god, there's no heals here.
There's no heals at all.
I swear I dropped a mini somewhere.
I don't need heals.
All I need is a tree.
Let's go this way.
Cause I feel like that condom team is gonna do the same thing.
We're gonna try to hold this out.
Alright.
Oh, I see a chest up there.
No.
Hang on there.
We're good.
Did you see shots?
I'm holding the trees just in case.
I'm holding...
As somebody that has no armor, I feel like I need to hold these trees out.
Yeah, if the moment that you get shot, just throw the tree down on your feet.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
This is why.
Oh, here, here.
I got minis.
I'm gonna toss them to you.
Wait, you can throw items?
Yeah, yeah.
You can heal over there.
And I'm gonna toss that one.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Right?
I feel like I should probably not use a plunger.
No, you can throw.
Oh, I throw.
I'm a tree.
Okay, yeah.
I know that, but...
Where do we go?
Alright, we're gonna go...
We're gonna keep going this way.
We're gonna go on top of the hill.
I've never been to the top of this area before.
Right?
Because the condoms keep, like, cutting us off.
I know.
They know we're right by...
I'm looking, I'm looking, I'm looking.
Yeah, tree, tree, tree, tree, tree.
You're good.
Look.
Oh, we're fucking chill.
We're fucking chilling.
Alright.
Drink.
I'm watching.
I'm drinking.
This team's gonna force to eat storm, I think.
It's okay, we have a tree.
Doggy, that was such a good reaction.
Keep doing that if we ever get shot at.
Oh my god, don't worry, I got you.
That was really good.
I have the tree out.
That was good.
I still have the tree out.
Watching for the team.
Okay, oh, I see them.
Chill in there, chill in there.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I don't think I have to meds for this.
Oh, they're fighting.
Wait, are they fighting someone?
Okay, follow my lead.
Stick to me and we're gonna go to the left, okay?
Ready, and let's go now.
Don't worry, I have another tree if I have to.
We can technically eat storm still, but...
Yeah, let's go this way, let's go this way.
I'm gonna toss a little crash pad and we're gonna go to the side.
I'm gonna toss another one.
We're gonna go over here.
Oh no.
And then there's a medkit here.
Oh, I need that.
I need that medkit so badly.
Take the medkit.
I need that so badly.
Oh, there's also a big pod here too.
Oh, there's another medkit here.
We're good.
I'm okay.
We are a group, John.
We are literally a group.
Oh no, I have to ditch it.
I have to ditch it for meds.
I think we're still chilling.
We're chilling.
Alright, and then we can start running up the hill here.
Don't worry, my tree...
I hear gunshots to my left.
Oh, team up here.
I'm gonna bubble you.
Oh, they put a bunker.
So we're gonna... I'm gonna cut to the left.
I'm gonna cut to the left.
Follow me.
And we're gonna use the bunk.
Or this.
What the...
Tree!
I'm gonna bug.
No!
It bugged me.
Play your life.
Tree!
Nice try.
I can't believe it.
It fell.
It's okay, I planted enough trees.
Honestly, I'm really, really proud of how you're playing that.
You're actually doing really good.
I unfortunately... I died to a bug, Doki.
Wait, what happened?
My characters, like, didn't teleport or didn't jump on the pad.
It, like, glitched me into the ground.
And then I had to run back on it.
Yeah.
I was like, well, GG's me.
How did they count in the tree strat?
I should have used my shot grenades.
I should have used my shot grenades instead of tree.
Honestly, I think what we're gonna do...
We're gonna do what this team's doing.
You see how they're just living in storm right now?
Yeah, yeah.
We can live so long if we just prioritize, like, medkits and stuff.
Wait, really?
I think we're gonna do that.
Yeah, like, look how long they get to live out here.
Oh!
Yeah.
We're gonna definitely do that next game.
I think that'll be the strat.
We saved the environment by planting trees.
We planted, like, at least five trees.
Bro, they hate trees.
These guys hate the environment!
Cancel them!
They don't want MrBeast to save the world or Fortnite.
They could have let everyone just plant trees.
Exactly!
They also don't even want anyone to have houses.
They're buying?
Wait, what?
They did not have shields.
That's crazy.
They can shop?
Yeah, if you have enough gold.
I think they've been, like, getting a lot of gold from the chests.
They can basically just keep on healing.
What the fuck?
These guys are just healing!
I thought buying wasn't allowed.
No, buying is allowed.
They just reset the gold each game.
Oh!
So you have to literally start from zero.
Maybe that's for day two.
Oh, that might be tomorrow or whatever.
Yeah, I think that was day two.
I'm going to send Fortnite an email and tell them to make me a Fortnite skin.
You gotta be your own skin, but then they're going to throw a little Christmas hat on you.
It's like, make me a Fortnite skin.
I will be a Fortnite streamer if you give me a...
Yeah!
They kind of have my skin in the game.
There's a werewolf in here.
I usually like running the werewolf team.
There is a day two, but we're not making it to day two.
What if we actually do make it to day two?
Is it day two?
Like, you gotta make it?
Wait, what?
Hold on, let me see...
Do we have to play day two?
I thought day...
Oh, I think we are playing day two.
I'm pretty sure.
We're playing day two?
I thought day two was like, we gotta make it.
No, I think we're actually playing day two.
Wait, what the fuck?
Total number of first place finishes.
Total number of elims.
Wait, why is there a day two?
It's gonna be on normal mode, so it won't even be on OG.
It's just gonna be like all the new stuff.
Wait, I think...
Yeah, I think we played day two.
We played day two?
I don't see anything saying that we have to qualify.
Yeah, we literally just played day two.
But like, what's the point?
The suffer more joke.
It's just the same game.
Wait, what's the difference between day one and day two?
On day two, it's gonna be the current build of the game.
Cause this is like a special mode that came out.
Oh, this is three strikes.
Yeah, it's like three strikes basically.
This is three strikes.
And then the other ones could be like regular.
Wait, so does the regular also have bunkers?
Um, regular has... yes, it does have bunkers.
But...
What's the difference?
There is way more... there's like different weapons and different like movement items and all that stuff.
So it's like a way, way different like style of the game.
I see.
Oh, it's just no reboots.
Yeah, no reboots.
All right, guys, we're gonna plant more trees tomorrow.
Guys, I read the rules wrong.
I thought it was... I thought like day one is like qualifies.
And then day two is like, you don't qualify, you don't have to play it.
So I was like, I'm not gonna qualify.
What I don't see is like, I don't know like what place gets paid what?
Cause like whenever I played in Twitch Rivals, it's usually everyone gets like paid.
Yeah, no, everybody gets paid.
Yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
So we just have to exist.
Yeah, exactly.
We just have to exist.
We get like literally $125 by just existing.
$125 McChickens.
Yeah, that's actually pretty good.
Under $25 just by existing.
And we're making memories.
We're having a good time.
We're literally watching houses get built.
We're watching trees get planted.
Exactly.
We're planting the trees.
And we're also doing it together.
Now I understand why the three Fortnite pros were like, I can't do two days with her.
Cause like, I guess I like feel like one day then they're fine with that.
But like two days might be like a bit too much with me.
Never.
They just don't know how insanely cracked you are.
The moment that you get your time to shine.
Yeah, exactly.
This is just the beginning arc.
We didn't have time to shine yet.
We didn't have...
We didn't have our moment.
We didn't have a proper gunfight.
Basically get to just watch everyone else.
And we're gonna thrive off of everyone else's energy.
Yeah, yeah.
Like we're gathering...
Like I'm learning how to play the game right now by watching others.
Oh, thank God.
Get rid...
Oh, what the fuck?
Holy shit.
Who is this guy?
I love that they're using the mammoth pistol.
That's that like revolver that they're using.
Oh my God.
That pistol is actually so good.
That guy is crazy.
Oh, never mind.
Get fucking comedy or curse.
That's fucking right.
Oh, it's my condoms.
The reboot's disabled.
Oh, it's the condoms again.
I feel like the storm doesn't hurt as much.
Because this is...
This is build mode.
I mean, zero build mode.
Sorry.
He's gonna die in zone.
Is he gonna live?
Oh, by building a house.
That sounds right.
Oh, condom down.
Condom down.
Wow, they're just...
He's just throwing their game.
Condom dead.
By the other condoms.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that flick?
He actually hit it too.
Oh, this guy's actually one HP.
Oh my God.
Wait, why is he dropping a weapon?
He has enough slots.
Wait, why did he drop his weapon?
I don't understand Fortnite players.
He has enough item slots for this.
Oh, they get to splash some HP?
He said.
There's no...
Yeah.
Oh, that's a skin I haven't seen before.
Wait, which one?
Oh, I'm going to another team.
Oh my God.
They actually have not matching skins.
I like this team.
Wait, this is a team.
Oh, it's this guy.
They swapped skins.
Wait, which...
Oh, is it the guys with the pink skirt?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They actually have skins that don't match.
Yo.
They actually have color in their skin.
That's crazy.
Seeing like actual color.
Oh, the guy's going to heal.
We're still like...
There's still so many teams.
What the fuck?
Oh.
I love watching this with you because like, even though I know what's going on.
It's why I don't play this game competitively because the tick rate is horrible in this game.
Oh, is it?
And yeah, in like in zero build, it's literally like diet build mode.
Oh.
And for me, I'm just like, yo, I'm not trying to play diet build mode.
Like I chose zero build for WKing.
You really?
I wish you can just edit.
Like the organizers just don't tell anybody.
They just edit the bunker to like 1% spawn rate.
I wish you could just do that.
Oh, that'd be so sick.
For one game, they edit the spawn rate to 1% and I just want to know what they're going to do.
I want to know what the players would do.
Like, what do we do?
What do we do?
I can't build.
I can't believe it.
The place I landed had no bunkers.
Like, what is my luck?
And then everybody just doesn't know.
That's not that they have terrible luck.
It's that it just wasn't spawning.
Right?
It's like, my RNG is horrible, actually.
Oh, I'm rooting for this team.
The colorful team.
Yeah, the colorful team.
As long as they beat the condom team.
That's all that matters.
That's all that matters to me.
Oh, they shockwave now?
Oh!
Oh my god, the reaction time for it.
And they rebuilt the house.
Right?
They actually rebuilt the house.
Holy shit.
What the fuck?
The thing is that this is only slightly sweatier than normal reload lobbies.
I wouldn't say slightly.
Like, it's definitely sweatier.
But like, reload lobbies are pretty sweaty.
They're like diet rank mode.
Oh my god.
Are they going to shockwave them out?
Is that a shockwave?
Wait.
How come we can't do that together?
Oh, they're going to build a house.
They're going to build a house.
Oh my god, they did it.
They built the house.
Let's go, colorful team.
Oh, and they're destroying...
Oh no, I missed that one.
How do you hit it so that it destroys it?
You have to basically throw it at an angle where it's going to connect with the player next to it.
Oh, so it has to connect to the player.
Oh, so the launch bricks that has...
It has to be like an LOS, yeah.
Oh, that makes sense.
Wait, somebody's living behind them.
They're squatters.
Oh, the squatters are gone.
Let's go, colorful team.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
Who the fuck shot him?
Yeah, right?
Yeah, who the fuck shot him?
Shoosh, get out of here.
Dude's shooting our pink...
Oh no, don't worry.
He's holding a porta potty.
He's holding it.
Porta potty.
He's holding the porta potty.
I'm going to start calling it a porta potty and a house now.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, what the fuck?
No, is it condom versus condom?
There's one solo alive.
Wait, who's the solo?
Oh, the solo.
There's one solo non-condom team alive.
Let's see, wait.
Oh, is it non-condom?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He literally has one.
Wait, no, it's actually a full team.
Yeah, they did it!
The non-condoms won!
They literally had zone.
They had zone and they just built like several fucking bunkers to make their own building.
Dang, was that three games out of five?
That like they're all non-condoms?
Yeah, they're all non-condoms.
I mean, they still have a small-ass hitbox because they're playing like the girl skins.
But maybe our next team should be the girls.
Yeah, what skin do you want to run?
Okay, wait.
What girl skins do we have?
I don't think I have any.
Wait, really?
I don't think so.
I think all my skins are guys.
Wait, do you have any like furry character skins?
Let's see.
Wait, I have a girl.
I have Evie.
Oh, I have her, Adria.
And then...
Wait, put it on.
I don't fucking know.
Like, I don't know what this is from.
Oh!
I don't know what it is.
I have the 2.0.
She's from the very first season of Zero Build, I think.
Oh!
It's like when I re-installed Fortnite because I literally did not play Fortnite until Zero Build came out.
And then like I played it for a little bit.
And I was like, alright, there's tanks in this game.
I'm good.
I went back to Apex.
Oh, you have Oscar.
I have Oscar.
Wait, if you're going to be Oscar, should I be the shark?
Wait, the shark?
This is ZZZ.
Or should I also be a different variant of Oscar?
This is doking.
I could be, um...
Oh, where's the other one?
Oh my god!
Is this a squad?
Is this it?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Our fucking hitbox is so bad.
I don't know.
I don't know about our hitbox, though.
I'm worried about our hitbox.
Alright, do you want to be the...
I have tomato, boy!
I have a classic!
Oh, be food!
Be food!
I have tomato head!
I can be a food skin, too.
Oh my god!
Here, let me swap.
Let me swap mine.
Oh my god, okay.
I wanna... I'm gonna be food.
I'm gonna be food.
Yes!
Wait, that's so good!
Oh my god!
Wait, this is so good!
Tomato and corn!
The perfect duo.
Where's my gritty?
Yeah!
Let's go!
Team tomato and corn!
Yeah!
Eat your veggies!
Eat your vegetables!
Eat your vegetables, guys!
Now I wish I had more Fortnite skins.
Now that I have two days of Fortnite, I wish I had more Fortnite skins.
I'm about to literally just give to you some random ass cursed skins.
Now that we have each other added.
Oh my god!
Wait, I remember there's like this funky ass emote with these guys, isn't there?
You have it?
Oh yeah, you're talking about the one from the Battle Pass, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw it on Twitter.
Oh, where is it?
Where is it?
You have it?
I can't remember what it's called.
I do have it unlocked, yeah.
Is it this one?
Yeah, here it is.
We're team veggies.
I quit this one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's this one.
Yeah, I saw that.
I saw that funky emote.
I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, did they have the code out yet?
Yeah, they just posted it.
Okay, I was going to say, it would be funny if we missed it again.
Alright, we're good.
We're good.
Alright, going radio.
Nice.
Wait, what are you using for your pickaxe?
I'm using the poultry pummelers.
Oh, the poultry pummelers.
I'm going to beat them up with meat.
Oh, is that the one that's in the shop right now?
I don't think so.
I don't see it in the shop.
I bought it before for the Peter Griffin skin.
I have drumsticks.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's perfect.
Okay, I'm doing that one then.
And then, what's my glider going to be?
Oh, wait, I have the ice cream sandwiches.
The ice cream sandwiches?
My gliders are like... I don't have a lot of gliders.
Not a lot of cool ones.
I have a lot of battle pass ones.
My only cool one is literally Shenron.
That's literally the only cool one I have.
Wait, really?
I have a car.
I like that one.
Wait, you have a car?
You have Regalia?
No, I have Victory Vaunter.
I also have the Woolly Mammoth, the monster truck.
Oh, do I have that one?
The Woolly Mammoth?
Oh, I have...
Do you have the Inflatable Horse?
The Inflatable Horse?
No.
What?
Yeah, I think it was like a Witcher.
It was like a Witcher Unlocked.
What the fuck?
The Inflatable Horse?
Yeah, I know.
I definitely do not have that.
Yeah, eat your veggies!
Everyone else is sweating and you two are having fun and vibing.
Yeah!
Eat your veggies, everybody!
Listen, Doki and I assembled literally an hour before the tournament.
Yeah, we were not ready.
We are vibing.
We accept our fate.
Doki was like the only Fortnite player that was like free.
I would say we're doing pretty damn good.
We're doing pretty good.
We're better than the Overwatch duo.
That's all that matters.
Let's go!
Wait, where's the Mercy res?
Wait, there's a Mercy res?
That's what the Overwatch players are saying.
They're like, where's our Mercy res?
Where's our fucking Reinhardt shield?
Oh, that's so cute!
What's the other one that's similar to that?
Merry Christmas!
Merry Christmas, everybody!
Yay!
I mean, are you using the bathroom?
Yeah, how do peas pee?
Literally.
Do they even piss?
Zorro!
Yeah, I wish I spent more money on Fortnite.
You're gonna probably get random gifts from me now.
I think I have like zero crowns.
Look at my zero crowns, everybody!
Yo, zero crowns?
Oh, I got the bird!
Yeah, do you have the one too?
Wait, no!
Wait, no, I didn't!
I didn't buy bird, it's the worst!
No!
It's okay, in spirit.
You have bird, it's the worst.
Yeah, you do bird is the word for me.
Oh, I love this one.
What is that?
He like makes it pretty hard, I think.
Oh no, he just sparkled.
Oh, there we go, he does make it hard.
Oh,
this is fine.
Wait, that's such a good emote!
Oh man, I wish I...
It's so big too.
Oh, I wish I bought this.
When you use it in game, it's ridiculous.
I wish I bought the Lethal Company dance one.
Did you buy the Lethal Company dance one?
Uh, yeah, do you have that one too?
No, I didn't!
I wasn't on Fortnite.
Alright, you're gonna get gifted the next time it's in the shop.
Wait, what does it look like?
Um, it's... oh, do I have it equipped yet?
Oh, here it is.
It's so good.
I love it.
It's so funny.
It's so good on, like, all the skins too.
I don't think it looks bad on anyone.
He's gonna meet the quota!
We're gonna meet the quota, guys!
We're meeting the quota!
We're not gonna be in Dead Last!
Yeah!
I think it's Macarena.
Oh, they have Just Dance?
They have Just Dance?
Oh my god.
I think we just get to vibe here and just do all these emotes.
Yeah, everybody else is, like, fucking, like, strategizing now.
I know my place.
Oh, there's Chewbacca!
Wait, you have Chewbacca?
No, I can buy Chewbacca.
Wait, what do you have?
Do you have, like, Han Solo?
I think out of all the Fortnite skin collabs I have, I don't think I have any ones from Star Wars.
You don't have... Oh, you don't have...
Let me see.
Yeah, because it's Lego, but it includes Chewbacca.
Oh, no, I do.
I have, like, Darth Vader and stuff.
No!
You don't have Han Solo!
I have a Clone Trooper.
I have Ahsoka.
And then I have...
No, we can't match because we don't have Han Solo.
No!
Oh, do you have Princess Leia?
No, I don't.
I don't.
Because you can buy Chewbacca right now.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, they added Chewbacca?
Yeah, they added Chewbacca.
You have to buy the Lego Pass, though.
Oh, that's where it's at.
Okay, it's in the Lego Pass.
Yeah, but you can, like, get Chewbacca regularly.
Oh, I forgot to put on a back bling.
I'm sad.
It's okay.
I'm naked on my back.
Look at all these condom people.
Is there any non-condom players in the lobby right now?
Alright, cool.
We got our spot.
Oh, we're landing.
We can actually drop right away.
I'm gonna do it right now.
Yay!
Alright, chat, game number six.
Let's fucking go!
Wait, is it game number six?
I thought it was game five.
I think so.
I think it's game five.
Is it game five?
No, it's five.
Okay, game number five.
Let's go!
Summon the fucking dragons!
Slowly drifting down.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
I got crash pads.
Ooh, that's good.
Alright, what's in here?
A shotgun?
I got a shotgun.
Let's see.
They're all guns.
The moment I stop being Mr. Beast, there's no more trees.
What the hell?
Trees?
It's actually crazy.
The trees just stopped spawning.
I actually have zero trees.
Well, we are the plant, I mean.
Or the food.
You're the vegetable.
It actually stopped spawning.
The game knows.
Oh, hey, a sniper.
I'm outside your building.
Okay, I'm trying to see what I'm... Oh, there's one more.
Oh, there's a tree here.
Oh my god, one tree!
Yeah, one tree.
We got one tree.
That's all we needed.
Oh, I got more Gibby bubbles.
Nice, we need that.
I'm gonna drink my shield.
Alright, I'm gonna see if there's any shields over here.
Oh, we're also in zone, too.
Yay!
Okay, I feel like I might not be able to snipe here.
Everybody's always close range.
Yeah, I've been thinking about what I'm gonna run.
And I think I'm gonna swap up my weapon.
I have the crash pad.
Oh, you do?
Oh, same, same.
I have six.
Okay, I'm just grabbing stuff over here.
I'm coming back.
We just don't have the porta potty.
We're just missing the... how are we gonna build a house?
I have four Gibby bubbles.
I have six launch pads and two shockwaves.
Oh, sweet.
Okay, okay.
You're a shockwave master now.
And trees.
And trees?
Okay, sweet.
Oh, I got houses!
We got a house?
We can afford it!
Alright, I'm going back to you.
Oh my god!
Guys!
We're gonna make it!
I think we have to just chill here for a little bit.
Oh, you know what we can also do too?
Were there medkits here?
Uh, there were like bandages, but not a medkit.
We might be able to live storm again.
We can do that strat.
Remember how that team was living forever?
Yeah, I'm gonna try that.
I'm gonna try that.
Did you grab the bandages?
Because there was...
No, let me check up here.
I know I dropped some.
We also have a lot of space to work with and we can like go all the way over there too.
But...
Oh, what do I drop?
There's a butt?
Do you wanna...
Butts?
Ayo?
Do you wanna build houses or do you wanna make Gibby bubbles?
I feel like the house is stronger.
When I saw like 200,000 houses and like two Gibby bubbles, I feel like people were running houses more.
I'm gonna drop the houses and I'm gonna try to find some heals.
Because we also have to move too.
But we can also move with storm.
We're gonna like eat storm.
Because it's pretty far.
Wait, you're not gonna pick up the bunker?
Oh yeah, I can pick it up for now.
Yeah, because like I'm gonna try to find us medkits and heals.
But we're gonna go slow with storm.
We're gonna go at like 10 seconds.
I don't think that team's gonna come over from...
Where we've died before.
Knowing them, I think they're gonna rotate like all the way in the south, so I think...
Yeah, we're gonna try to go back to looping.
Alright, let's start going.
Alright, let's go.
Team Veggies!
I see a team on the island, but we're gonna go with storm.
Okay, let's...
Oh, there's a team on the right.
Crouch, crouch.
We're gonna chill here.
Please leave us alone.
We're just poor little veggies.
We're trying to save the environment.
I also have a lot of jump pads, so that way we can keep rotating.
Not last.
Yay!
It's all that matters.
How much gold do I have?
I only got 9 gold?
I have 9 as well.
Okay, let's go in this bush here.
Come up here.
We're gonna look around.
Oh yeah, there's definitely still a team on the island.
So this is good.
I don't have any meds.
We're gonna find meds to the left.
We're gonna go all the way over here.
What if we don't?
If we don't?
GG.
It's because your plan relies very heavily on the meds part.
This guy is also healing.
I think we're good.
Okay, let's go left.
I'm a little concerned because...
I'm pretty sure I did find meds here earlier.
I fell down.
Oh, you fell?
Oh, here.
I got a crash pad.
Here you go.
I think that should work?
Does it work?
Goodbye.
Oh, here.
I'll toss you a med kit.
I'm gonna toss you a med kit.
Goodbye.
Hello.
Yay!
Wait, do you have any heals though?
No, I can find something though.
I'll find something.
There is a bunch of chests up here.
Oh, I got splashes.
Yeah, we're good.
Nice!
I'm gonna light a campfire.
And then I got more splashes.
Oh, there's more bandages.
Alright, so I'm gonna splash us once this thing goes out.
Alright.
Because if I splash us now, it goes away.
Oh no.
We can live here forever.
This is our new home now.
We're drinking some grape juice.
There's nobody here.
I can even...
Oh, what the fuck?
I cracked him.
I knocked him.
Okay, I'm gonna push.
I'm gonna push that.
Oh, he died.
He died.
Okay, let's go left.
Let's go left.
That was actually so fucking terrifying.
I was literally... I was literally trying to jam out.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Jokey.
That was fucking terrifying.
That was so funny.
Holy shit.
At that moment, I was like, there's nobody here.
Finally, Emo and I see a guy next to me.
I was chilling and Emo and this dude's running up like, yo, word?
I think we're good here.
I think.
There's a bunch of where I want us to get to.
Okay, I'm trying to head there.
I don't know if I can...
Oh, I fucking have a crown.
I'm so dumb.
Oh my god, again.
It keeps on respawning on us.
Yeah, you have to... what's the word?
You have to drop it, right?
Yeah, if I drop it, though, people are going to see it on the map.
So, I'm just going to chill here.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm good here.
I'm going to look around for heals.
I'm in the bush.
I feel like there's going to be a team on top of the tower here.
Not if I'm in the bush.
I'm terrified.
I don't know if there's heals here.
I'm so scared.
Dude, this bug FPS died like four times.
It wasn't... I didn't see him die like four times in this game.
Okay, Doki, I'm going to try... we have to move forward.
So, we can try to get over here.
Or we can get to here and build a house together.
Okay, I believe in the house stack.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to actually burn a bubble on this because I need to see if there's heals on here.
Heals?
There's no heals.
Oh no.
Okay, I'm going to your bush.
Trying to ping what's in.
Someone is getting closer.
I see the blueberry juice coming in.
Let's go to this bush.
Oh no.
There you go.
We're good.
I'm looking.
Wait, where did they shoot you from?
Over here?
I'm going to go behind.
I'm okay.
Oh, are they in the bush?
I think they might be in the bush over here.
Where is here?
Let me see if I can ping it.
Right there, I think?
Oh my god.
There they are.
Where are they?
I'm going to... they're like hiding in there.
In that bush in front of us?
Yeah, they're literally in that bush.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Wait, where did you go?
I'm behind you.
Oh, there you are.
Okay, we can keep... Oh, actually, Goki, I have an idea.
Here, run back to me.
Yeah?
And we're going to cut all the way to this on that.
Okay?
I'm going to toss a little jump pad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get ready and let's go.
Oh, I'm being fucking bugged!
You missed it!
No, it's bugging me.
It's bugging me.
Okay, just keep going.
Keep going.
There we go.
Oh my god.
This game...
I'm going... Oh my god, it's bugging again.
I hate it here, dude.
I'm okay.
I feel safe.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
I'm okay.
I found bandages.
I'm here.
I'm going to toss this down.
It's okay.
I'm here.
I launched pad like two times to get here.
Alright, we're covered on both sides.
We're good.
Okay.
I feel safer.
I'm just watching the other team behind us.
Holy shit.
Where's this RPG coming from?
Wait, is someone RPGing?
Yeah.
Oh, I think I know where.
It's... I'll ping it.
I think it's right there.
I hear like...
Doki, if we get pushed, I'm going to immediately just shield bubble.
I'm going to give you bubble.
Okay, okay.
Should I come to you or be in this house?
No, no.
You're good on that side.
Alright.
Oh, that's you.
Okay, I was like, who's that?
Yeah, I see a team that's fighting over here.
Wait, there's like a shield potion right in front of me.
Oh, there is?
Oh, that's good.
Okay, yeah.
You can pop that then.
I'm going to...
Yay!
I should probably not peek that.
They're fighting to our side?
I don't have an angle.
You can feel free to shoot whoever just so that way we have presence.
What's that sound?
Oh, that's people responding, I think.
Oh!
Oh, the respawn is ending.
Okay, I was like, what the fuck?
Oh, we're good here.
We're literally chilling.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel a little safer now.
We're chilling.
Oh, there's people in front of us.
Oops, I shot my house.
Oh, I hit that.
I randomly griefed this guy.
77 on someone?
Don't you love just griefing people in VR?
Is it safe for me to go up here?
I'm terrified.
I could get shot from there.
Yeah, I know.
It's so terrifying.
Can I peek this?
I can't even peek on the right.
There's so many gunshots.
Come on, come out of that house!
If this bunker is safe, I'm going to...
Oh, yeah, there were people here.
There's people going to be right here on the left.
Okay.
I don't have an angle on that.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Yeah, the only thing is, she was in front of me.
And a little bit to the left.
If you get shot at, I can throw the bubble down where it can connect on your side of the building.
Yeah.
I think I'm fine for now.
Like, I still have this house.
Yeah.
Yeah, we made this house.
This bar house.
Oh, they're coming out of the house.
Oh, wait, never mind.
Okay, so we are going to have to move.
But...
Okay.
I have one house I can build.
Alright.
We can try to get over here.
I feel confident with that one house.
Actually, Doki, come to this side of the house.
Because I think what I'm going to do is I'm going to make a launch pad.
Wait, you can come inside the door.
No, I'm going to die from this.
No, I'm here.
No, no.
What the fuck?
What the fuck, Doki?
You didn't tell me I could open the door.
I can't.
Okay, we're going to have to go.
No, we're going to go.
I'm going to die.
Yeah, I'm dying.
No, you're going to live.
You're going to live.
Oh, you're good.
You're good.
I got you.
Why didn't you tell me that the door...
Alright, so this might be a GG.
I'm dead.
You said go over.
I was like, okay.
I think that's a dead climb.
There was a door on the other side.
I can't tell there was a door.
I got so confused.
No, you can't climb.
Oh my god.
All I heard was go over.
I was like, okay.
You mean there was a door?
Oh my god.
I think my favorite part about that whole scenario is that you could have literally walked inside safely to the other side and you weren't around.
I thought that.
You said go over.
Oh my god.
I said go over.
I'm fucking crying right now.
That was so funny.
I can't see the door.
Oh my god.
I got so scared.
Guys, we got a kill.
Guys, that's all that matters.
We got one kill.
We ended on 50.
You know what?
No, no, doggie.
We have consistency, okay?
You know these things don't have?
They don't have consistency.
Exactly.
We're never last.
They're not ending on the same number as we are.
Every single round.
We're 15th place Andes.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, the houses are real.
I swear, we died to the Christmas theme so many times.
They want to wish us Merry Christmas in July.
Why are they always next to us?
I swear, it's like they know.
They're like, look, these guys are the different people who keep on becoming other skins.
Yeah, they know.
They fucking know.
That was the fucking best one up, Joe.
They know that's us.
Holy shit, they figured out our tracks.
I'm literally crying.
My cheeks hurt from laughing.
That was so fucking funny.
I don't know what it looked like on their stream.
They tried to climb the house and get knocked off.
Wait, are they alive still?
Are the Christmas people alive?
Yeah, they're still alive.
Wait, who was it?
I don't know, they're anonymous.
They're anonymous.
Yeah, we don't know.
Oh my god.
I want to watch their POVs so bad.
They're going to be like, why is this guy running outside?
I didn't know there was a door.
I don't know.
Wait, what the fuck?
He threw a trophy at us.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, they died in one second.
I like, fucking closed my eyes and they're dead.
That is some OG ass thing I've never ever seen.
What the fuck?
What is that?
What are they holding?
They're holding a giant, like, a giant trophy.
What the fuck?
And then they, like, throw it?
I've never seen this before.
That's how, like, not OG I am.
What are they doing with the trophy?
I think it one-shots.
Oh, it does 200 damage in one hit.
What the fuck?
How did you get the trophy?
Fuck, FPS is still alive?
This man has died, like, this is the fifth time I see him died on the kill feed.
How is he still alive?
I want to watch this guy get a kill with this.
Are they just, like, is Buck FPS just landing on somebody and just his other duo is just, like, waiting until, like, he respawns?
Like, what's the strat?
He's coming back.
Oh, is this guy gonna live?
I want to see him throw the freaking fish at someone, even though it's a quantum skip.
Wait, that's so risky.
Like, yeah, he's so dead.
Just throw it now.
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
No, you guys threw it out of the hell, man!
No!
You could've thrown it!
You're dead already.
He was gonna die anyway!
Oh my god, thank god, thank god.
Let's go!
Only one cotton team has won throughout this tournament.
Chad, you hear that?
Quantum skins don't help you.
Yeah, they don't help you.
And you don't have fun.
You will never have fun if you have it on.
That's my favorite comment in chat.
Oh shit, sorry.
Out of context, by the way.
I did not mean it like that.
I'm freezing.
Oh no!
STDs is a problem.
Oh no.
Oh, I'm fucking dying.
I'm dying.
Oh my god.
I'm making it worse.
I literally cannot.
I cannot right now.
Doki, I didn't know I was gonna literally die of laughter this entire tournament.
This tournament.
Wait, what's our thing this next one?
What are we gonna be?
Oh yeah, last one.
Yeah, it's our last one.
And then we have day two tomorrow.
Okay, then we have day two.
Wait, do you have any Futurama?
Oh, I do.
I do have Futurama.
I have Bendy.
Okay, I have Leela.
Oh, you don't have Fry?
No!
No, I do have Fry.
I have Fry.
Fry and Bendy, let's go!
Fry and Bendy.
Fry and Bendy, I'm gonna go get a golf club.
Yeah, we're gonna be pay to lose looking at it.
Have you ever seen how big these freaking skins are?
Yeah!
They are so ridiculous.
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Are we winning?
Oh, we are totally winning.
We're winning in life.
That's all that matters.
We are consistent on our placement.
We got one kill last game.
Pay to lose.
What are you?
I'm gonna use the stop sign.
I'm running out of skins for tomorrow.
Do Fortnite skins change hitbox size as well?
No, I believe they're all the same.
There might be like three different variants, I think.
There's like the very chonky big skins.
That's why you see all of them use that same fucking skin.
Over and over again.
Giant Chicken Riot?
We were already Giant Chicken.
Yeah, we already did Giant Chicken.
Somebody wasn't watching.
Yeah.
It's there.
Look in the VOD.
I love you.
I don't.
Fuck you.
Yeah, cry!
I'm gonna use the Giant Inflatable Horse.
This is the win team right here.
41312 hours.
This is it.
I believe.
Last game, guys.
This is last game and then we'll be free until tomorrow.
Oh my god.
Are you ready for tomorrow?
Are you ready?
Today was just the warm up day.
Today's just the warm up.
Wait, you haven't played this season, have you?
No, of course not.
Dude, you're in for a treat.
There's so much to digest.
Holy shit.
In the current season.
After this game, we gotta play one chill lobby.
I'm down to do a chill lobby.
I'm down.
I wanna know what it feels like to actually shoot my gun.
No, you shot your gun once, right?
Yeah, I shot my gun once last game.
But still, I wonder what it feels like to shoot more than one time.
You know, get a kill, you know?
I wanna know what it's like to be top 5.
Oh, we're gonna get so many top 5.
We're gonna get a top 1.
Oh, it's okay.
They've posted the code yet.
Oh, they haven't?
Thank god.
Oh, they're typing it right now.
Oh, I can Radiant Events.
That's good.
Thank god.
Oh yeah?
Oh shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They have... Oh wow, you're right.
They did add League of Legends back in.
I didn't even notice that.
Oh?
Wait, they stopped typing.
Doge, are you gonna be a Fortnite streamer now after this tournament?
If I get a Fortnite skin, I'll be a Fortnite streamer.
You hear that, Fortnite?
Yeah, Fortnite.
You hear that?
Doge, Doge's skin or Riot?
Yeah.
If you don't...
Imagine, imagine the money you'll make...
Having a VTuber skin.
They have no VTuber skins yet.
Yeah, imagine.
Imagine.
I am all in all for a VTuber skin.
And some furry skin.
Even though they already have a lot.
The fuck?
Don't listen to him.
I just want...
My skin.
Doge, doge your Riot.
Yeah.
I just want my skin.
I can't believe that guy had a...
A golden flopper.
Or whatever it's called.
It's like apparently really rare.
Yeah, that's what like...
That's what peeps are saying.
Yeah, everybody's like, oh yeah, that's so rare to get.
And then he threw that trophy and the guy just died.
It was like blunt head trauma.
We got to like watch one person die to it.
That's all that matters.
It's fucking crazy.
We witnessed a murder.
We witnessed a lot of murders, but like...
That murder was like extra gruesome.
Are they streaming the tournament right now?
Well, I mean, it's Twitch Rivals, so...
Oh yeah, Twitch Rivals.
Yeah, cause you forget we're in the Twitch.
Like, why are we playing?
I saw that it was like State Farm.
I wonder if State Farm is streaming.
Oh, we got the code.
Okay, we got the code.
Nice.
Guys...
I wanna...
Doki a Fortnite skin.
I have children watching me.
Even though they're not supposed to.
I found out.
There was a child...
There were children at my panel during a convention.
So I know they exist.
And Fortnite...
Yeah, one of my conventions I did.
I was like, I hope there's no children here.
Because I'm gonna swear.
And then there was a Q&A time.
And then they gave a microphone to a child that was like...
11 years old.
Cause I was like, how old are you?
And he's like, 11.
And I'm like, fuck.
And he just like...
Shriveled into a very...
Shriveled up reason.
I was like, oh no.
Children should not be watching me.
I wonder if Twitch Rivals has shown us like...
Surviving.
If they want content, they gotta like...
Be in our call.
Oh,
there's condoms over there?
There's condoms over there?
And we're the Coco Melon of YouTubing.
Yeah, that's me.
What do you mean?
We literally...
Are you okay, Doryu?
No, I'm not okay.
We're literally the characters.
Everything's a blur.
How?
Wait, we gotta let...
We gotta let Fortnite know...
That we do have children in our audience.
Because Fortnite loves knowing that there's kids watching us.
Cause that's...
People who spend money.
Apparently.
They watched us when we were Morty under the bridge?
When we were what under the bridge?
Remember when we were Morty and...
Oh, we were...
Yeah, they were watching us.
Nice.
All I'm saying is that...
Oh, they're showing the standings.
Oh, no.
You don't want to watch that, Doryu.
We're gonna be in 15th.
I'm calling right now.
I saw somebody mentioned that we were last at one point.
So you don't want to watch it.
They obviously were not in last.
Obviously.
We've been playing out of our minds.
No, it's gonna break your heart, Doryu.
I wouldn't...
It's gonna break your heart when you see it.
Yo!
We're only two points behind the...
The other teams that are behind us.
Or in front of us, I mean.
There's three teams that have eight points.
And we have six points.
Wait, we have six points?
We have six points.
How did they get eight points?
I literally see...
J3 died.
First, like, 200 times.
That's because we're consistent on not dying.
What the fuck?
Oh, they get kills.
Because we're just doing placement, but they have kills.
Oh, that makes sense.
That should make sense.
It's not fair.
Seriously, the people around us are like the sweats that make it to top five every time.
Is it really?
Yeah, we have the condom people and the Christmas hats people right next to us.
Oh, you're right.
It is the Christmas hat people.
It's the Christmas hats and the condoms.
It's not fair!
I wonder, since it's the last game, if we're gonna get, like, ego sent on.
Maybe, for the points?
Yeah, they're probably gonna be like, Mmm!
We killed one of them last time, though.
That's true.
Oh, I have Macarena.
All it took was you to be like, Wait, there's someone here!
And then we literally locked onto them and just destroyed them.
Wait, let's sync up the Macarena.
Okay.
Ready?
You should keep a count.
Three, two, one, go.
Macarena.
Yeah, no one can do it like we can.
Yeah, at least we're having fun.
Yeah, what are those guys doing?
Not having fun?
Exactly!
They're too busy strategizing.
We're peak Fortnite gamers.
Fortnite's not about sweating, it's about skins and dancing.
Yeah.
That's how they got 5 million followers.
And RP servers, where you emote with Chun-Li and...
The richest Fortnite streamer!
All they do is dance and eat, dance and buy skins.
We embody the real Fortnite gamers.
We are playing for the people.
Yeah, we're the people.
You think the children are building 500 houses?
No!
They're out there being fucking bender.
They're literally bender and emoting.
And being every Jujutsu Kaisen skin variant.
Exactly.
While playing Fortnite Festival.
Use my creator code, JokeyBrit.
Oh, I have that too!
Oh, you have that one?
You have the My Hero Academia skins?
No, I didn't.
I just bought this.
I wanted this with John Cena.
Oh my god.
I did not think of that comment.
That's actually terrifying.
I bought this emote just for John Cena.
Or for the people.
What is happening to my eyes?
We're gonna plant trees!
We're gonna plant trees and burn plastic.
Yeah!
Cause it's all about the balance.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
I love how everyone has that same reaction with this emote.
I had the same reaction when I first saw it.
I'm like, what the fuck is he riding on?
What the fuck is that?
Ballerina, dancer, metal, rock and roll.
This is how you dance to metal, right?
This is the world that we grew up in.
Zero.
Yay!
Doesn't this reset every season?
I know I've won Fortnite games!
Oh yeah, it resets every season.
I was like, why did I have zero crowns?
It doesn't even cover my hair.
Wait, it doesn't?
Yeah, the umbrella.
It's got a big ass head.
Go Doki, give us nothing!
Chat, what is this one?
I don't remember having that.
Nice if I had a crown.
Obviously, chat, we're gonna kill the whole lobby.
This is different.
Oh my god, there's condoms all around us.
Wait, I've never seen these guys before.
They must die before they can do anything.
Oh, I see you.
Oh, did you drop your crown?
I did.
Nice.
Nobody wants to join our band, they know we're losers.
We were cool before they even knew what the word cool was.
Alright, let's go!
This is the one!
Alright, let me know when to land.
Okay, let me ping it.
And then drop...
now.
Oh my god!
We got the floaties!
We got the little floaties!
Yay!
Bender has summoned Shenron!
Alright, here we go again.
I'm gonna laugh.
These guys are gonna probably shockwave on me one day.
Like right now.
Oh, I got a shockwave!
Oh, I got trees!
Let's go!
Tree time!
Oh, I got more shockwaves?
I'm getting faster at looting.
You can see each game I'm improving.
Dang!
See, they don't even know.
Oh, they're trying to push me.
Wait, are they actually?
Yeah, they're actually pushing me.
Wait, that's not good.
I am gonna do this.
Guys, let's play the game!
Shockwaving?
These guys, I knew they were gonna be so horny for me.
Right here?
Where are they?
On my bunk?
Wait, where are you?
I'm on your rooftop right now.
I'm gonna loot.
They're not gonna kill me, right?
Nah, they're gonna kill Fry.
Yeah.
They burned their three jump pads, so...
I'm just gonna get up.
I have those splash juices.
Okay, yeah, just loot everything.
I'm gonna push on the rooftop.
I'll tell you if they push or not.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Stop pushing?
Are you still chilling on the roof?
Yeah, I'm still chilling up here.
I'm just watching for them.
Hello.
I'm gonna smash splashes.
Oh, yeah.
Splash.
You're gonna get shot.
I hope you get shot.
Oh, you fucking get shot, dude.
There's a...
There's a shield potion here.
Oh, there is?
Oh, can you grab that?
I'm gonna chill up here.
I'm gonna keep watching for them.
I'm pretty sure they just, like, ran.
But we're gonna, like...
We can eat some storm and we can literally wrap all the way around here.
Or we can swim all the way around over here.
Okay.
We're living this.
We're living.
Yeah, we're survivors.
Oh, there's...
Why is it peaked again?
Oh, I see a condom scene down there.
Wait, where's the...
Where's the shield at?
Oh, I can drop it.
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
Honestly, we can probably just go...
We can go in the water now.
Here, follow me.
Alright.
We're gonna eat storm.
We're gonna get some weapons.
I have bandages, so I'm fine with that.
Oh, you got bandages?
Sweet.
I'm gonna laugh.
This guy's gonna be in the bush right here.
I'm calling it right now.
No, please don't.
Please don't.
Please.
Please, I'm scared.
I'm just a robot.
Get to the left.
I'm just a little robot.
At least you got bandages.
The only thing you gotta make sure of is don't heal until we're away from the scene because it'll show an indicator when we're healing.
Oh wait, really?
Yeah, it's all for that sound thing, yeah.
Oh, so that's why everybody has it on.
Yeah, and it'll show that and then you can just see all the footsteps and stuff.
It's really, really good.
Oh.
We're so good.
Guys, guys, kill this duo!
What is he doing?
Oh, I got bandages.
We're good.
Okay, we can heal here.
There's some pads here if you need movement.
Oh, yeah, I'll take that.
We're living.
I feel alive.
I feel so alive with my 40 HP.
Oh my god, I see a team out here.
Okay, chill inside.
We're good.
Oh, they heard me bandage.
They're all the way across.
No, I don't think they saw us.
I see one.
Oh, they definitely see us.
Almost cracked this guy.
I'm just gonna slide to the side.
I see them.
They're in the bunker, yeah.
It's fine.
I just want to apply pressure just so that way they keep on moving.
Oh, I got a medkit.
Okay, I'm bandaging.
Okay.
I'm gonna chill on the roof.
Why are you doing it?
Leave!
We have none of meds for you!
Keep on looting the house.
Come over here to this house.
And then we can see maybe there's heals over here.
Oh, they just bonked again.
Stop wasting your resources!
So real.
They're right there.
You're gonna get nothing from us.
Oh, they threw a medkit.
Okay, well I'm gonna have to heal.
I have more bandages so you need some.
Okay, just keep on holding on to those.
You can play that angle.
Oh!
Okay, I guess not.
They might push.
I'm watching.
You can heal.
Yeah, it's fine.
I just popped the medkit.
I'm good.
I'm good too, I think.
I'm gonna get on the rooftop.
I'm gonna non-stop heal.
There's another launch pad.
I'm gonna grab those.
Yeah, but you can shockwave away.
Wait, they have the crown?
What the frick?
Timing?
Okay, I'm gonna shockwave to the right.
I'm gonna go right.
I'm gonna try to get ahead of them so they don't wrap around us.
Should I come over?
Uh, yeah.
Come on over.
Wee!
Oh, I fucked up.
Woo!
So I'm just trying to find some heals.
We can actually go through here?
Those bandages.
Oh yeah, there's bandages.
There's bandages.
Oh, do you need shockwaves?
I'm good.
There's a heal here.
Do you have any gold for me?
Oh, no.
I have zero.
I didn't realize you need money.
Okay, you're good.
Oh, I have a medkit.
Yeah, just go and heal on that.
And then we're gonna have to, like, run into storm on the... or run from storm.
Um, on this next one.
Oh, there's a chest here.
Oh, I found bandages?
Sweet.
Oh, I found splashies.
Oh, huge, huge, huge.
Okay, you can just use them on yourself.
And then, um, I'm gonna have bandages for us.
Oh, I have gold too.
Oh, we got medkits here.
There's medkits.
Oh, I need those.
Yay, I'm gonna toss it your way.
And then, uh, come out from the cave over here.
Uh, just come towards me on this side.
Okay.
Then I'm just gonna toss it here at the edge.
And then, uh, before you use your splashes...
I already used it.
Oh, you did?
Okay, use those first.
Oh, where's the medkit?
Uh, it's to the... it's right below, uh, right here.
Oh, okay.
Wait, where?
Oh, it's right here.
I got another one.
Oh, it's right there!
Okay, it's my turn.
Grab it.
I can grab it.
I'll toss you another one.
I'm coming back.
We got 30 seconds and we're gonna have to start going.
I think I see a team over here.
We're medkitting up now.
Okay, I'm gonna medkit too.
Oh, I see a team's literally on the edge.
No, leave us alone!
Uh, where's this next one?
Oh my god, this zone pull sucks.
It's not until we eat, uh, I think 500 storm damage that it starts doing storm sickness, so we should be okay.
Storm sickness?
Yeah, that's where, like, you start taking, like, increased damage rapidly.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, there's gonna be a team on the other side of that mountain, but we should be okay down here for now.
More running over.
I'm scared, though.
Okay, we're gonna go left.
Oh, there's, is that, is 9 gold enough?
No, it's, uh, I think 50.
Goddammit.
Wow, no one is dying this game.
Please don't tell me that was to me.
Okay, I'm gonna shockwave over here, Doki.
Okay, I need healing.
Okay, I might be able to just run in.
I had to heal.
Yeah, you're good, you're good, you're good.
Why is everybody being careful?
Oh, there's nobody!
Oh, no!
Are they shooting you?
Uh, jump yourself, or launch yourself.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Oh my god, there's a team here!
Oh, respawn, respawn, respawn.
Live!
I'm living, I'm living, I'm living.
Just live!
I'm living!
You're gonna be good!
Live!
In 5, 4, 3, 2, 1!
We're good!
Wait, I should just die in the... Oh wait, no, I have nothing.
I didn't realize you lose everything.
You can land on the house, land on the house right there, the one I pinged.
Okay.
Please be nobody, I'm just Bender.
Alright, I'll let you know if there's people in here.
Alright.
There's nobody here for now.
Where is this team at?
They're like, in storm?
Jesus, I'm hearing all of these fucking noises.
Oh, it's ending in a minute.
I'm going in.
I'm here with you, I'm here with you.
We inside this.
I'm gonna give you the jump pads for now.
Okay.
Don't worry, I have 500 guns.
Ayo, you got 500 guns?
Oh, you need ammo?
No, I'm good.
I have ammo.
Okay.
Next zone is...
Do they have 200 RPGs?
Oh, team coming over?
I think?
Where?
From which direction?
People here?
Wait, there's teams on top.
I don't have SMGs.
And a rifle.
I'm trying to see what I can...
what we can play.
Oh, we can go this house.
Okay.
We're gonna try to get to the blue house, okay?
Okay, how do we get there?
Let's burn a shockwave where your jump pad to get over, okay?
Get to the blue ping, I'm gonna go now.
I think there's actually a team in here, but I'm going in.
Oh, I see a team outside.
I'm safe inside.
Oh, he saw me, they saw me.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
It's a lower cross.
They saw us, they saw us.
I think they're gonna try to push us.
100%.
I'm just waiting for the bubble to go down.
It's gonna go down in 3, 2...
Oh, no, never mind, they tossed another one.
It's gonna go down in...
3, 2, 1.
Okay, they burned another one.
They burned another?
Yeah, they're just trying to prolong the...
You know how it'd be in BRs, they're just trying to live.
Yeah.
I see them, they're running to our left.
They're running to our left.
Okay, this is good, we're chill inside.
I see them, I see them, they're to our left right now.
They might try to get to here.
On the roof, yeah, yeah.
They should theoretically get shot at by...
Oh, they're underneath, they're underneath.
They're gonna try to climb on this.
Are they wearing a shotgun?
Oh, they're climbing.
They're climbing right here.
They're right here, right here.
Okay, watch the staircase.
Okay, I'm gonna go underneath, go underneath, go underneath.
Come, come, come.
What the?
Oh, I'm trying to move.
Oh, sorry, I'm sorry.
They're getting shot, they're getting shot.
Oh, god.
Knocked one, knocked one.
Thirsting, I got the thirst.
It's okay, I got the thirst.
I'm good.
I got the thirst for you.
I got the thirst.
Oh, god.
Just live, we have a point.
I'm living.
Just live.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's another team, that's a full team, that's a full team.
Live in the bush if you can.
Live in somebody's house.
Faster, hustle.
There's a point.
You get a point.
We got a point, I was trying to get the other one.
Oh, my god.
We got a point.
That's what it is.
Yo, Doki, we placed 13th, we got 13th.
We did better.
Wait, you killed the guy that's in first?
That's a victory?
Wait, what?
Oh, no, you're saying that's a victory in general.
Oh, no, we got, we got, we killed somebody.
That's a victory, yeah.
We got randomly rocketed, it wasn't even the same team.
Wait, really?
No, we could have got two points.
You didn't notice our sneak and kill, yeah.
Yeah, because I was like, no, there's three of you.
Bro, they should remove rocket launchers.
Remove bunkers and rocket launchers.
That's all I want.
Random RPG moment.
Is there a special rule for killing the first place player?
Let me see.
I don't think so.
Because he still lives.
He's the one that got dokey in Storm?
Epic revenge moment?
Yes, let's go.
Nice, fuck them.
Yeah, fuck them.
Eat a wiener, end game.
Or IRL, if that's your thing.
I love how you broke into that guy's house just to kill him.
That's fucked up.
That's so fucked up.
He's probably like, leave me alone, bro.
I'm just here.
Let me see the rules.
Let's see.
Format.
Total number of players in the event.
Oh my god.
There's only one condom team.
Wait, only one condom team?
Yeah, there's only one.
JK, there's two.
The other guy's a solo.
Wait, no, what?
How is this...
What the fuck?
Hey, they have high ground.
How do they always have zone?
This is not fair.
These guys are on to something.
Oh wait, what the hell?
Oh, that's the POI.
I was so confused by that giant metal structure.
Wait, is that POI?
Or like...
It's like an iconic thing, I think.
Yeah, yeah, because there's a llama.
Oh, that's what it is.
It's a llama.
Yeah.
It's a llama, so it has to be part of the structure.
To kill the number one player that makes you number one?
Yeah, that should be the case.
It's true.
Oh shit, they knew he was in the bush.
So smart.
Once you play the game long enough, you eventually just never trust bushes.
You're like, I hate bushes.
Oh, that's the number one player, I think.
Which one?
The one that just died.
Oh yeah, fuck that guy.
I'm watching the...
I should not give the condom people views.
I'm watching the plunger people.
I'm watching a grandma team right now.
Oh my god, they're growing trees.
They're planting a tree.
The item shop just refreshed?
Thank you for the real updates that I care about.
Hey yo.
What's in the item shop?
Are there any cool emotes?
The thing I actually care about.
Oh?
I'm watching a red-headed team.
I'm watching the plunger team.
They have the plunger gun.
They're the ones that has a push.
Oh, the guys with the push!
I think these guys have won a bunch.
They've won like two games back to back.
Did they?
I can't tell.
They're all the same.
They're all the fucking same to me.
They're all on novice mode.
Get off of novice mode, you fucking pussies!
Who's stream-styping you?
Who?
I'm telling you.
You're literally the voice of the people.
Oh, they're getting pushed by a condom.
On 5 HP.
Oh, they got on a condom.
I'm watching the grandma team again.
Oh, the grandmas are dying.
Oh god, not the grannies.
No, let the grannies live.
Oh, the granny team's dead.
To a condom again.
Oh shit.
It's like redheads versus condoms.
And just one guy.
Just one solo.
That out of context sounds so good.
Oh my god.
Oh, big brain.
Oh, but they're dead.
My god, this guy's level 445?
That's a Fortnite player right there.
What is this guy?
Level 167.
I'm watching somebody that's...
I'm watching Feast right now.
Isn't he an OG Fortnite player?
Oh, who is?
Feast.
Oh, Feast?
Everyone's a no.
I can't even spectate them.
No!
It's okay.
Get out of my screen.
I'm not even gonna watch you dance.
Oh, he said Feast.
I'm so dumb.
I thought he said Feast.
No, no.
T-H-I-E-F-S.
Yeah, Feast is actually really good.
He's like one of the players I knew when I saw the list.
We want your feedback on a scale from 1 to 10.
How would you rate 1?
I strongly disliked it because the condoms won.
Negative 69.
Alright, let's play one game.
Oh my god, we get to play a normal game!
Let's go!
I wanna be Mr. Beast.
No, I wanna be John Cena.
I'm gonna be John Cena.
Who do I play as?
Play as you dream.
As content.
Let me play as...
I can be a big cat man.
Alright, let's see.
John Cena with the pom-poms.
Yeah!
John Cena.
I'm gonna be a person.
Oh, you're right.
Thanks for the reminder again.
I forgot.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Will, the song singer!
They added so many emotes.
Oh my god, they added emotes that matter to me.
What's this?
Oh!
Let him go!
Let John Cena go!
Oh my god!
Alright, wake up.
What's this?
Alright, I know which one I want.
I know exactly.
Okay, Pirates of the Caribbean.
Okay, they did not refresh these.
Oh, what the fuck?
Is that a monkey?
Ayo?
Wait, what?
Oh, I didn't see the rest of the shop.
There's like a monkey.
Is that it?
Oh, the stock monkey!
Yeah!
There's a monkey.
So ugly.
Okay, I know exactly what I'm gonna buy.
Oh my god.
Okay, so we are playing tomorrow for sure, I guess.
Yeah.
Dang, look at us.
We made it through day two.
We fucking did it.
We made it through the day.
Alright, I got new emotes.
Let's see.
Let's see, where is...
I wanna see what the standings were for the end.
Did that one point matter to us?
Did it?
I wonder if we actually got more points than the other teams that were ahead of us.
They were only ahead of us by like two points.
You're a duck!
Oh my god.
This is what I bought.
Oh, you have that one.
Yeah, fine.
Let's call it Gunslinger, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pew, pew.
And I have this too.
Oh, look at him go.
Look at him go.
Go, Cena, go.
Show those moves.
Oh, don't see what's going on.
Look at him go.
Go, Cena, go.
I forgot to ready up.
Oh, I forgot about that.
I forgot about the actual part of the game.
No, we're playing the game right now.
Oh my god, now we can actually play the game.
Wait, okay.
Oh my god, what would it look like?
I'm proud of us.
We got 13th on our last game.
Yeah, we improve.
We're consistently improving.
That's all that matters.
One of my really, really goated Fortnite buddies was like, I know 90% of that lobby list, and you guys did really good.
You know what?
That's all that matters.
I told you!
My bodyguard!
I told you I'd block all the bullets with my big body.
We did it!
I'm not fluffy for any other reason.
We got our bodyguard.
Mixxy!
Hello, Mixxy.
Yeah, I know.
We're continuing on the trend of condom skins.
Alright.
Nice!
Oh my god, I get to actually play the game.
I get to actually play the game.
Holy shit, I swear to god, if I see a fucking bunker person, I'm going straight up to them and shotgunning them in the face.
Yeah, let's fucking go!
I feel like I played against Fortnite pros today.
You don't matter to me.
You are nothing.
You're beneath us.
Oh my god, you have pom-poms!
I do.
You're all beneath me.
I fucking played against Fortnite pros.
Who carried ten buildings.
Who is this loser with thirty- fifty-eight crowns?
Get out of here!
Get the fuck out of here!
Fifty-eight crowns, you loser!
Get out of here!
That's fucking right, my crown.
Damn.
They were like, nah.
Nah.
Alright, I'm ready.
Alright, where do you want to go?
Where do you feel like going?
I don't know.
You have railways.
Let's fucking do it.
Railways.
You see that icon on the map?
The skull?
That's like the best medallion in the game.
And it randomly spawned over here.
So we have like a hell of people here.
Holy shit.
We can kill them, right?
Oh my god, why are my frames dropping like crazy for this area?
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
I destroyed the first spot!
It's not even coming to us!
I killed one!
Come on, I'm with you.
I'm scared.
Freaking die!
I killed one.
We're good, we're good.
Wait, is there loot on you?
There should be, yeah.
Okay, I'm just gonna head to you.
Knock knock!
John Cena, he's here.
John Cena!
And his name is...
Oh?
I got ammo.
Oh, they ran.
Okay, well...
What the fuck is this?
I have Nitro Splash.
Is there a gun?
And then here's the ammo.
Nice, okay.
And then once you're done popping those, stand next to me and I'm gonna hit these canisters here.
Okay, I'm just gonna grab this gun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're good.
And this too.
Alright, I'm good.
What the fuck is this gun that you got me?
Flint Knock Pistol.
Okay.
I'm ready.
Okay, so let's hit these.
And then I'm gonna do this and you can run forever.
There you go.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
JustDV, get shit on!
Yeah!
This team's dead!
Oh my god, what the fuck is happening?
Oh, get fucking...
Where are you?
I'm alive somewhere.
Where the fuck are you?
It's a Peabody!
Where is the Peas?
Where is he?
Oh, god.
You guys won?
Oh, I'm pushing him.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I'm going in, I'm going in.
I got lost.
There's too many doors.
How do I get out of this house?
Life has too many doors.
How do I get out?
Fuck away, chest!
We're alive!
We're good!
We're good, we're good.
Everything's fine.
I don't know what guns I'm holding, but everything's fine.
Oh, you're not like... You're like owning right now.
We just fucking own some humans.
Yeah, that's right.
Get fucking shit on!
I need this.
Can I eat my apple?
Oh, I'm gonna break in.
I'm gonna steal some gold.
I'm gonna steal...
Ooh, I'm gonna steal a cabbage.
Do you need any like...
ammo for your flintlock?
No, I'm good.
How many bullets do I have?
Is this one shot?
Yeah, it's like a one shot, but it acts kind of like a shotgun.
And it also launches you into the air.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's what I felt.
I was like, what the fuck?
Was that what was happening when you were fighting him?
Yeah, I was like fighting him.
That's fucking right.
Knocked one.
Nice, get over here.
That's fucking right.
Get out.
Where is he?
I cracked his kite.
No, I missed!
They're dead!
That's why I was like, no.
I'm gonna try shockwaves.
There we go.
Oh my god, I'm actually one HP.
Holy shit, I have cabbages.
You want cabbages?
Yeah, yeah, don't make it count.
Okay, here's some cabbages.
Thank you, Doncino, you're my favorite.
Don't worry, I'm here to feed you.
Don't worry, little duck, I'm gonna feed you some cabbages at the lake.
Alright, let's go to the left.
Alright, I'm fucking going.
I'm feeding some ducks at the pond.
We are fucking owning.
Way better than these guys could own.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay.
Alright, let's keep going left.
This is a shotgun.
Run and gun harbinger SMG.
Is that good?
Uh, the harbinger?
Yeah, what color is it?
Green.
Yeah, it's not too bad.
It got like crazy buffed.
I think like a few patches ago.
Oh my god, I'm listening to Twitch Rivals in the background.
I have the nitro splash.
Oh, you have nitro splash?
Is that the...
That's the one that you splashed on me, right?
Yeah, that gives you like um...
infinite sprinting.
Oh, okay.
Here, I'll give it to you.
No, no, you should use it.
I don't know what I'm doing.
All you gotta do is use it and then you start going really fast.
I can split it with you.
There you go.
Alright, sweet.
I'm gonna pop it and we can start sprinting.
Alright.
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, you destroyed a fucking bush!
Yeah, you can literally just run through stuff.
You like break everything.
Can I run through this?
Oh shit!
John Cena's here!
Holy shit!
That's crazy.
Oh no, I don't have it anymore.
It's going left for like, I think, what is it?
10 seconds?
I think it's like 10 seconds.
Wait, somebody's here.
I hear footsteps.
Oh yeah, that might be them.
Run me, run me.
I ran too far.
I cracked one.
Nice.
I cracked the other guy.
I knocked him.
Where is he?
They're dead!
There's another vehicle here.
Nice.
Alright, give me your shit.
Oh my god.
Give me your shit.
Give me your fucking shit.
What is this?
What did you throw at me?
What the fuck?
I'm going to swap my flint gun.
I don't want it anymore.
I'm done playing with you.
I don't want to play with you anymore.
I got a sniper now.
I cannot wait to find the movement item of the season.
Because you're going to be like, what the fuck, League of Legends?
What?
Have you ever played League before?
No.
I still have a life.
Tell him.
Get in here.
We're going to go for a little drive.
I'm heading over.
You're going to drive your own car?
I'm next to you.
Wait, you're right.
Where did he go?
What the fuck happened here?
Look, it's all broken.
Wait, you're right.
What the fuck?
There's people fighting.
They have the medallion.
We don't have any movement other than our infinite nitros.
That's enough movement for us.
We're going to kill you.
We're going to go to them.
We ain't no pussies.
Yeah, we don't have anomalous mode on.
That's when you know we're gamers.
I'm going to get out of here.
Get out of the car.
Sorry for calling you pussies.
They're right here.
We're going to kill these dudes.
He's fucking running.
Stop running, bitch.
Oh my god.
I'm going to reload.
We're good.
I don't have an angle on them.
There's people behind us.
Oh shit.
They're gloving away.
I might be fucked then.
We're good.
I'm going to run back the way we came.
Okay.
Because I might...
I'm looking.
Help me.
Oh, he's so low.
I knocked him.
Where's his buddy?
I'm going to come to you.
John Cena's going to live.
John Cena did not live.
They're dead.
Pick me up.
I have bandages on me.
Oh no.
John Cena, please.
I need to be the people's champion.
Okay, we're good.
You can heal.
I have bandages.
Okay.
I'm going to toss you one.
Yeah, I'm going to catch it.
It's like baseball.
Where is it?
Oh my god, it's so far.
I'm going to toss you a big shield.
Okay, got it.
After you're done.
Oh my god, we're alive.
We're still healthy.
Oh, they're shooting.
They're still shooting.
We can full top off over here.
Let's go back over to the train station.
And then we're going to top off.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
John Cena wants to eat everything.
I think.
By the way, this is legal.
I'm drinking legal stuff.
Oh shit, we're out of bigs here.
I have heals.
I have gold.
Oh, you do?
Oh, it's out of stock.
Oh, I thought you meant like...
That's...
Yeah, I was going to buy...
See, you call them shield bats too.
I fucking call them shield bats.
Oh, they're coming over.
What the fuck?
Are they driving you?
Yeah, they're shooting.
They have a machine gun on top.
Oh, they're going to keep running, I think.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, they're gone.
They're gone.
That was a drive-by.
Alright, well...
I guess we can keep looting here.
I can't believe we don't have any movement.
There's actually so many movement items in this game.
Yeah, like what kind?
They have these gloves.
Oh, the magneto?
They have the magneto gloves, but then they have these gloves where you can launch yourself in the air.
Oh!
Oh, they came back.
They're leaving!
No!
Wait, what are they shooting at?
Wacky inflatable guys over here.
Alright, well...
Let's try to find...
I want to like...
Top off on heals.
I can't find any.
Yeah, I can't find any either.
Is there any down here?
I don't like bullets.
Wait, what gun is that?
Laser rifle.
This place is so dry.
I got distracted and do every match?
Oh, that thing's hitscan.
Oh, that's what I like to hear.
Where do we go?
Let's go this way.
Oh, I can't ping.
Alright, well the game's ping system sucks, but I'm trying to ping over here.
I'm just going to follow.
I follow.
Follow the duck.
Don't worry.
John Cena never dies!
Do you have nitrous?
Yeah.
Oh my god, we can run on water!
We're Jesus!
Oh my god!
Just like Jesus, my hero.
I fucking knew he was Jesus.
The almighty, powerful duck.
Oh wait, more nitrous?
There's nitrous in here if you need.
Nice.
What's this?
There's a repair?
Oh, that's for the car.
Yeah.
We can actually drive.
Oh, I got an idea.
We're going to try to get some movement.
Grab those nitrous.
Which one?
I don't know why it keeps doing the shotgun.
Yeah, I got it.
I'm trying to unping that.
We're getting the car.
Let's go over here.
There might be some movement over here.
There's also stuff we can heal on.
Like these.
Wait, does that heal you?
Oh, the cactus!
Wait, that's so cool!
The cactus, they regen in the desert area.
Yeah.
And the desert area has a higher chance of spawning the gloves.
So I'm going to check over here.
To see if there's anything.
Yeah, you have 16 seconds.
We're also pretty close to zone 2, so we don't have to run for 5 ever.
Oh, and a nitro drill!
Let's get out of the car here.
Then we can just run around here.
My god, this place is sick.
Right?
These were one of the medallions spawned at 2.
This place is fucking sick.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
What's that?
Does that hurt you?
Uh, the flames?
Oh, the flames?
No, I'm talking about the fucking spinning.
Oh, the blades or whatever?
Oh my god, I got a house!
You got a house?
I got a house.
It's over for them.
It's fucking over.
We have real estate.
Alright, well, at least we ran through there.
This is what we're going to be playing on tomorrow.
Oh, this map?
So people are just going to...
Wait, did you claim a spot for tomorrow?
Uh, no.
Wait, can we actually claim those right now?
I don't remember.
We gotta look at the rules.
Yeah, I'll look at the rules and I'll see if I can claim something.
Am I basically a VTuber?
No, I'm a werewolf IRL.
He's a werewolf.
He used to be, when I met Doryu, he used to be a fleshy.
And he got bit by a wolf in between.
That's why, I don't know.
I was like, yo, being a fleshy is cringe.
He got bit by a wolf.
So now he's a werewolf.
I know a wolf that also knows a wolf.
And then...
They also know another wolf.
Wait, are they all werewolves?
These things also are going to give us the nitro too.
Oh, shit.
Nice, we're super fast.
Do you want those shockwaves?
Do you want to keep practicing with those?
No, I'm good.
I've already mastered it.
I don't need anymore.
There's a tourney coming up?
Uh, so we're doing day 2 of the tourney.
Today was day 1.
And then tomorrow is day 2.
But we were doing on a reload.
Yeah, I thought...
I thought day 2 was when you qualify.
We did qualify.
Oh, it's true, true.
Guys, we qualify for day 2.
That's how good we are, guys.
Only 20 teams can qualify to day 2.
And we made it.
Wait, what?
You don't take fall damage with this either.
So you just jump from here.
And there's Baja Blast down here.
Oh, there's Baja Blast?
What does it do?
You walk into it.
And then look what you do.
You literally become Tracer.
Wait, how did you do that?
It's a double jump.
Woah!
And every time you touch the Baja Blast, you get the dashes.
Wait, how long does it last?
It lasts forever.
It'll stay on you as long as you have the charges.
So you only get 3 charges.
Oh!
Okay, Baja Blast time.
Dude, Fortnite changed so much.
I know, right?
Wait, there's someone here?
Where?
I knocked a wolf man!
Where is he?
I killed him.
Where's his teammate?
You think you can get away?
I fucking have Baja Blast.
Yeah, tell him!
Fuck him up!
Oh my god, he has Nuka Cola?
What the fuck does the Nuka Cola do?
It heals 75 shields.
And then I think it heals like 50 HP.
What the fuck?
What is FalleN doing here?
They have FalleN?
When will they have Doki Bird?
They're throwing.
They gotta add Doki.
What's that?
We need to teleport you over here.
Where is... I hear gunshots.
Gunshots are on top of the hill.
They're over here.
Let's go.
Alright, let's fucking get it.
I don't like them.
I don't like them either.
Yeah, I don't like them.
I'm gonna kill them right now.
They're in my lobby.
I already hate them.
I'm gonna nitro here.
Where?
Can we run up here?
What the hell?
My character is teleporting.
I'm gonna nitro us again.
And then...
I'm gonna shockwave.
Did I shockwave you off?
Did I shockwave you away?
No, I'm gonna run the baby way.
Oh my.
I'm coming down.
They are handholding like crazy.
Moments before disaster.
These guys have all the movement.
And I'm just a little dude.
They're handholding.
I looked at them and I died so fast.
I am going to...
Yeah, I can grab your card.
This is teleport.
I keep lag teleporting.
I died so fast.
Yeah, I literally was up here about to fight one of them.
And then they literally both handheld on me.
I was like, what is happening right now?
It's okay.
I have 200 seconds.
I got you.
You got me.
I have nitro too.
I have nitro.
I got your discord nitro.
We're going to live this.
Are they fighting?
It's so safe.
This is the slowest rez ever, but we're so safe.
No.
I'm proud of y'all.
Holy shit.
That movement though.
Wait, they're fighting now.
I might be able to get in.
No, they're camping the rez.
That's fucking right.
Is this guy buffed?
I see them.
Oh, they thirsted him.
Is that medallion good?
It gives me unlimited ammo.
But...
I don't think it's going to be what it will save me.
Oh, the gloves!
Is that good?
Yeah, it's good.
Holy shit, what is this movement?
What the fuck?
You literally traveled across the map in one second.
I told you, the movement in the other mode is so cursed.
Oh, no.
This is going to be tomorrow.
Oh, we are...
Oh, I get it.
I'm proud of you.
Oh, no.
Wait, is the hats going to exist tomorrow?
I think so.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, my God.
It took the whole game to find gloves.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
We got to deal with that tomorrow?
Yup, yup.
Oh, wait, it said hands are not in rank, nor are cars.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I really... I don't think I would like to play.
I don't think I'll have fun with the pros?
The pros with the hands?
I don't know.
You got hands.
That's what they don't have.
They don't have hands.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Thank fucking God.
Gee, geez.
I had fun.
Gee, geez, Doki.
What a great day one.
Thanks for dropping by like an hour before the tournament.
I really appreciate it.
I was actually joking with my boyfriend about how I have this luck with Fortnite where I will always get pulled into something very last second.
And I'm like, you know what?
Fuck it.
We fall.
I'm just going to go all in.
Fuck it.
Thank God.
Gee, geez.
I'll see you on day two.
I'll see you day two.
I miss your face.
It's been a long time.
Let me know if you want to play a bit too before the tournament.
Yeah, I think I do.
I think I definitely need to warm up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, I'll see you later.
Alright, bye Doki.
Bye Doryu.
Bye everyone in Doryu's chat.
Oh my God.
That was so fun.
I had a fun time.
Just playing with Doryu and just like being dragged around.
I didn't realize...
Wow, Fortnite changed so much.
Thank you everybody for watching.
I guess tomorrow, also, we're going to be playing Fortnite tomorrow for day two.
So, there's going to be more of the tournament with Doryu.
So if you guys want to check it out, it's going to be same time, 2pm PST on Twitch.
It always happens.
Every time I'm resting, there's a Twitch Rivals tournament that I get invited to, which I think...
It's happened a lot.
I realize it has happened frequently.
It's a pattern.
But it's been really fun.
I've been having a great time.
It's fun to...
I haven't talked to Doryu in a long, long time.
Like I said, I knew him back in Apex.
And he was still a fleshy.
Now he's a werewolf.
Now I have a werewolf bodyguard.
But I'm glad that we had somebody to do this Twitch Rivals with.
Because like I said, we went through three different Fortnite pros and then I'm so happy that Doryu was able to sub in at super fucking last minute for us.
And with Twitch staff helping us too.
But yeah!
I really appreciate everybody for coming in.
If you guys don't know me, my name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTubes, but today I am on Twitch for the tournament.
Usually for Twitch Rivals.
I am on Twitch for Twitch Rivals.
So please check me on YouTube.
If you guys want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, please follow me on Twitter.
We have a lot of promo stuff.
You guys know my Gamersub code.
You can support me via other means.
I have so many other ways to support me with.
Like Gamersubs, the Hyatt merch, the merch store.
And thank you everybody for all the subs, the gifted subs, the bitties and the follows.
I really, really, really do appreciate it.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Pause, check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you except for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!